number four isn't it
yeah see we got it there we go
ladies and gentlemen welcome to game
spots overwatch stream how you doing
chris waters and daniel dwyer here hello
chris it's going to be some awesome
overwatch time for the next many many
hours indeed nice winston's shirt right
off the bat oh yeah can you see that
like they're really tiny glasses i don't
think it comes here i just pick this
thing up
there you go he's winston i get it the
character nobody knows how to fly until
they play about a week of overwatch and
they're like oh god okay i can't just
kill everyone i gotta like jump around
like diva or they watch the game spot
overwatch hero guides hurrah yes watch
the ones we want put up now because
they're all the ones we know all the
ones later in the week not so much
uh but you'll be able to watch us play
this video game unedited for the next
couple of hours uh i'm here for two
hours with you chris we're gonna play
some overwatch hell yeah also gonna open
up some of these hot loot crates let's
do it um well we're gonna do the loot in
a little bit yeah i've got this i've got
this one just sitting here
i'm ready to jump in ready ready to do
it we've been authorized to go um i'm
going to open it in about half an hour
you want to buy them right now though
right now let's do it let's do it see
what happens all right oh god this is
our promise to you are you sure blazer
are you
yeah hopefully it works hopefully it
works oh god okay hey hey guys do a hot
switch away
we're not looking at danny's asterix how
many asterisks does he have it's only
three you never know oh here we go oh
okay
game you have 50 loser boxes
yay
all right let's open those later first
of all what a tease let's uh let's let's
play some goddamn overwatch i'm excited
play real quick you know the best thing
about playing this game now is is that
unlike all of the multiple bailiffs
chris we don't have to worry about
having to give back our skins every
couple you'll actually get to keep that
skin that you stumble into yeah that
legendary uh symmetra indian goddess
outfit which i rocked for most of the
beta so good so good i had the uh again
the winston
uh safari outfit yup i spent a thousand
gold on that bad boy that was pretty
good i think i also sprung for the lucio
like slap shot hockey player one oh i
didn't see that oh yeah it was great i
saw his um the one where he looks like a
frog
that was pretty yeah he's got like the d
like the dead mouse-esque kind of head
situation oh we don't have a sniper yet
so i'm going straight in all right we're
starting off with some attack on nepal
and uh oh no maybe oh yeah actually i've
swept up a couple of times on this
without have you danny i was playing a
match the other day with someone who was
like really feeling their widowmaker
yeah on an attack map and you know on
this assault mode
and you know you got to be getting a lot
of kills as widowmaker to make it
feasible because you're usually not on
the point you know what actually you're
not capping now that i think about it
i'm i'm setting the bar high here but
that's what you do for yourself when you
choose widowmaker on a map like this you
need to be just like slaying that's the
thing is that some people when they pick
widowmaker they think oh we're getting
like two or three you know i'm getting
like one or two kills every time i go
out there it's like if you know if you
want to be widowmaker you need to be
like getting three or four kills every
time you get at least yeah you gotta be
very really earning it and especially
with maps like this where you know it's
all about that capture point to be able
to like just peek in and disrupt the
enemies capture and then bop out is like
a really important thing to be able to
do it's tough to do that as widowmaker
not impossible the one thing as well
people keep doing at this do not go on
the point until the 10 seconds are off
you don't need to start mixing it up
nope don't get yourself killed before
the thing starts in fact let them all
sit there so that when this happens you
can murder the crap out of all of you
can just start blowing them up
go away diva oh damn it oh she's
gobbling them up
yeah that's like oh it's kind of like
going all hard in the scrimmage yeah and
then i just darn goofed and got killed
by a goddamn diva
is is diva one of those i feel like you
start to develop characters that you get
really annoyed particularly annoyed to
be killed by i mean as far as it's it's
bastion and widowmaker which are also
your kind of like responsibility mm-hmm
in this battle
case in point
all right so we need to start just just
start blowing them let's start blowing
some things up
get yourself some health let your
reinhardt push in there who the hell was
it oh
time for a little ferret duel nope oh
oh
i think you got a little help there but
uh hey all's well that ends well for the
team nicely done
now they're kind of ranging out to the
side there
and this soldier loves to pop in the
corner and just uh work that healing
biotic field thing no doubt
oh you wanna you wanna get the ring out
you wanna get that diva off the point
you've got justice ready
get around zenyatta is on you
but zenyatta so squishy
who's is that your reaper
yeah take them out that's your best
about
get her
be gone diva
i need you need a heel give me a heel
somebody give me a heel
somebody killed that diva oh
no who's the healer on your team you
guys have a mercy i think yeah
i mean she's probably staying with uh
our friend reinhard
hooray we got it
there we go oh it's already contested
let's try and do the old
pop a couple of rockets through that
area there
oh she's popped
where's she where is she
a little justice little heroes never die
and uh
oh
thomas couldn't quite get clear of the
diva
that thing i i feel like it surprises me
sometimes so far the gameplay is it's
not our it's not the gameplay's fine the
audio but like because i'm not hearing
everything i'm not hearing everything oh
do you want me to no no that's all right
it's all right i keep it
so like i didn't i didn't realize she
popped out until a little bit too late
get on the point everyone here this
i think one of my favorite parts of
overwatch is trying to imitate people's
uh hero alt
vocalizations
all i need to be doing now is just
getting some
dirty hits on these guys there's diva's
mac done
go away oh there she goes
oh almost got it
soldiers in his bub
just outside the freezing range all
right and you guys have got it back in
it they're pretty much even here
uh so now now do you like to just like
yeah you get a side angle going on the
income yeah go in behind the door i like
scooping up this health because it stops
them using it as well so yeah they're
denied
oh god i love it so much when the hero
alt line is just choked off
it's high nougat
thomas oh she got you the one thing you
don't want her to do is right
i mean i should have known she would
because we're so early in the game
there's a pretty uh pretty on it diva
get her team
there we go
yeah it is
stay away lucio
cheeky little monkey
he's healing and hopping around
all right 49 let's get down get that
health
live to fight another day
all right this is the situation you just
got to sit there
soak them up
oh that soldier come on you want it oh
you've got two pharah's going i thought
i had heard some justice on your side
oh look at that junkrat oh almost yeah
tasty tasty little glory shot at the end
there very nice all right we just a bad
guy i was not did not play a very good
game there but it was all right it's all
right this is the internal one so this
is one where she really needs to swap to
oh we don't have a healer great
i'll do that time for you boy
yeah lucio's pretty much i mean is he
like the healer to have on this one
because area heel is just so powerful i
mean people will it's so it's so
important on the points with him because
he's able to heal all the people
but he's also got the bump on this one
super useful as well because you can
just knock everyone off especially on
this map yeah because it's right the
point is basically 50 surrounded by
death pit all right everyone do not go
on the point yet hold up hold up hold up
all right good pro tips yep maybe just a
little hairy from long distance you do a
little bit of just
testing the waters you can uh
you can take off quite a lot with this
at the distance that far eye actually
almost killed completely
the other thing you got to be careful of
is the drop down back here all right we
need to be on the point folks get back
dude i did not even know that was our
thing
man i played this map like dozens of
times why am i the only one on the
[ __ ] point come on
there you go
all right let's do it
this is a map that i feel is uh is
pretty prone to strategies of doubling
up on heroes this guy yes totally he
hopefully that guy will get frustrated
and will and they'll charge in and you
can just peek right out
yeah that drop back back there is super
handy if you're having trouble getting
on the point i feel like that answers a
lot of mysterio a lot of questions for
me in terms of mystery appearances
uh
do you ever feel that it's worth it when
playing as reinhardt to charge someone
off the point and sack and kill yourself
oh
i mean
if you can't kill him by any other means
maybe maybe yeah maybe if it's just like
all right you're the you're the only one
in here giving our team trouble let me
just
throw myself on that grenade we we had
one game once where there was four
reinhardts and a bastion sitting right
here yep they tried they were shielding
that dude up which was pretty funny yeah
there you go speaking of which
they brought a bastion to the party oh
beautiful
yeah boston dealt with uh oh
spread out everyone
yeah don't oh she could stand right next
to you don't stand near each other
i'm not healing enough you come on group
back up
all right folks in the twitch chat i got
some questions here were you able to
expense the loot boxes yes the
christopher robin we uh did it for you
and uh we are gonna show you some sweet
loot box opening later in the stream
goofs you right we are currently playing
without a group uh this is our sort of
danny's warm-up matches for the day and
we're getting started and going unless
you played a little bit this morning i
don't know yeah i almost got her almost
got
yeah did you get too thirsty for it did
you get too hungry for the push he went
straight for me yeah look he's zeroed
down on yeah he knew no doubt
who else who else is here lucio always
handy to to wait around for someone else
as well yeah you look at those respawn
icons and the circle like if the
circle's almost complete you wait for
that reinhardt wait for that anybody
really help him get back in the fray hey
good game good good thanks chris nicely
done danny appreciate it who's going to
be not a gg
gg
not a gg it's just i mean what are you
offering constructive criticism there
you're expressing your own
disappointment
i feel like gg's not really usually an
objective analysis of like exactly how
this game went yeah
it's like all right good fair play
it's like it's a sportsmanship thing
like hey we endeavored together look at
that i got that little card as well oh i
just knocked out something i think
what happened
i think an hdmi pop oh look kind of back
in
all right
give me a hot second i think i think
and what did gameplay just do i just got
a new bottle i wanna got a loot box
don't need that i got fifty one of them
now baby hey man
every loot box could be that one you're
right i could be that one i almost so
are we gonna say that's the 51st loot
box is the one that i got at the end
yeah because i don't know if the first
loot box is the one you earned because
if we go dry for 50 boxes and then the
last one that ends up being an epic
that'd be beautiful that'd be poor
pretty cruel
all right this is a fun map for
widowmaker i'm just gonna say it this is
a fun map for widowmaker i feel like
route 66 is one of the more divisive
maps yeah
a lot of people don't for people a lot
of people not really feeling it oh
matt's in the mats in the group yeah
all right
thanks for joining us bud these are
reinhardt today
yeah this is a funny one i feel like
most people enjoy the middle of the map
because it reminds they think they're
playing team fortress 2 for a little bit
but they're not super hot on like the
ending is super hard to defend
that last corridor yeah yeah especially
if you've got some torbjorns and
bastions throwing stuff down i had
literally my best torbjorn game ever
yesterday in that stretch
on a real epic defense it was actually
on the stream that uh tay and mahari
were doing uh and i felt real good about
that because torbjorn's not a dude who
i've played a ton with tesbian 4.0
hanging out dude i love i love these
these areas it's like yeah give me
something to look at what is that bomb
he's talking and nobody explodes i love
the stuff that's on the menu uh you know
craft from the stars the comic yep oh
yeah the menu yeah
peas and thank you liver and onions
mashed taters i think this is where the
uh the new character's little detail is
as well
the
potential like sombra character that
people are hypothesizing about all right
enough for that
let's see who's out here
sometimes the idiots stand around here
and you can just like you just line them
up and then instantly click
click two more yeah yeah case in point a
bunch of tracers just being real idiots
that's a lot of tracers is that three
traces
yeah i think it might be
so who's your best anti-tracer character
i mean
like pharah probably but we already have
one
so it doesn't matter we'll just do this
instead and just kill them yeah go ahead
come by my doorway really stupid tactic
get that little launch off the top
boom oh baby i love me some widowmaker
right down that main line all right
maybe we shouldn't be grouping up so
hard like this folks this is a pretty
he's gonna throw that on top of the
it's just asking for a tracer alt to
come in and ruin all of your day
all right lucio you really need to be on
top of it here can we can we have some
some bounces lucio some health
i mean you guys can come after me all
day like look the point is on the other
side of the map you idiots widowmaker
ain't pushing the point you guys have
like two and three people on the point i
am more than happy to be the sacrificial
lamb of this team running backwards come
on and get me like no pro look how far
we've pushed already this is that's real
dumb
all right let's try and get some more of
these jerks
boom
i'll kill you from 200 yards away jerk
how do you like me now
i mean the only way to really do it is
to get a little bit of height and lift
these guys up that way yeah who are we
who are we looking at though here yep
okay
get my back
there
oh my god so much tracer noise figure
out where they are here anyways
are she right on they're all underneath
me i don't know oh trigger
works as intended
oh you got him a little bit winged him
my goodness the trace of madness is real
yeah i feel like far away question is
like your road hog should not be chasing
tracers back off the point your road
should should be chilling
yeah for sure um i expected you to
mantle right there but i think that's
just because i've been playing doom a
little bit lately
yeah there's not enough metal playing
right now
she's dealt with it anyway
all right here we go push into the first
check i mean i feel like in any other
situation i would not be with a maker
because it's usually hard to hit tracer
but these guys are such idiots that i
feel like i just want to be her anyway
and your team's doing fine you can
afford a little like you know uh
strategic leeway afforded by the fact
that you guys are moving the payload
effectively
pharah's just like taking him out like
it's going out of fashion come on lucio
where you up dude
no get off the speed line of sight no i
saw i saw little plus signs yeah
give me that sweet line of sight i need
to get out of here i'm just i'm i'm
being a problem as well by by mixing it
up yeah by indulging them yeah a little
bit getting caught up in that tracer
madness
i want to see a parody uh like book
cover or movie cover called tracer
madness of reefer madness that like
anti-marijuana propaganda oh yeah
just like
man oh nice yeah you got that little
little pop up top as well
they are they are tricky little i'm not
sure if they can get up here is that the
reason i'm
yeah he can always just
oh
almost had him almost
oh your thing's still moving
a little bit of a tag on snags oh yeah
there
and now what are you gonna do tracer
when everyone's breaking it down
like literally how many tracers on it
let's see the tab five it's five tracers
and one lucio this is this is like a
i like it though i mean i like
i don't know are you i'm a little torn
on sort of novelty comps right like who
is yeah it's fun to me to mess around
and
you know see how it all works it's
obviously not working out terribly well
in this case for the other team but no
and i'm kind of using it as target
practice actually it's kind of like
warming me up or something it is right
like i'm
it nothing to i mean you don't have any
tanks to aim at
there's no no big targets
but you're still still doing pretty good
work out here mr o'dwyer four of the
three of us are on fire
i mean i definitely shouldn't be here
once we get in here like this is gonna
be
a nightmare but
doesn't mean i can't take a couple more
of these jerks with me
you think it's going to get a little
tricky in there
look at them they're just getting swept
up
look at lucio here going to try and kill
me from a distance yeah good shout jerk
cool yeah let's let's toe to toe from a
distance yeah good one you don't want to
toe to toe with widowmaker from a
distance unless you're widowmaker or you
know maybe maybe hanzo they got a yeah
we have a switch folks to
soldier 76 is at least two of them now
it's fine they can't close the distance
as fast as you can i'll just keep doing
this oh they've missed like four times
they can do their little biotic field
situation like how far we've pushed the
payload already like that just cruise
through that entire corridor they
haven't
just stick one on there so i feel like
i'm involved a little bit they're not
getting way too close for somebody who's
supposed to be sniping but whatever
yeah you can afford to deviate from
normal tactics to uh hassle that lucio
nice work nice pursuit by matt pasquale
as the reinhardt oh get away oh
mccree
he's gonna get you got your back thanks
bro
yeah that was fun and experimental
overwatch builds
a bit of a cakewalk that's so good for
the other team good job swag kitty
swag swag kitty this one i love this i
love that uh skin with a scarf the scarf
is so good
yeah this is what you were saying what's
a good counter to tracer yeah pharah i
mean this fire is not even doing the
right thing you need to be in the air
tracer's only like just drops a tag
still works
all right let's give it to uh let's give
it to our boy matty for pushing the
push that payload baby
yeah like fire in that situation the
only way tracer's ever going to kill
afar is if far is on the ground even
then fart wasn't doing what fire should
be doing and still imagine and we're
still blowing up a bunch of tracers have
no health that's far damage baby i mean
yeah and pharah's projectile is like it
deals so much like it's one of the
single most
uh powerful projectiles in the game
individually so like
it's just ridiculous that yeah i don't
know what they were doing
all right we got pushed back do you
wanna
open a few loot boxes let's open a loot
box or two we had a question we need to
open them all are curious oh all in one
go yeah we need to do them on one go we
do it all right folks here it is we've
bought 50 loot boxes and earned one as
icing on the cake uh if you want to
cancel your search for the game danny
we'll really get into the loot box
opening here all right did we get the
first one yeah first one's looking nice
and blue
come on baby yeah can you detect the in
did they move it back to detect being
able oh yeah put i mean make the
vermouth what is that
it doesn't look like a vodka bottle
that's all it's yeah it's just a player
icon i don't wanna there's who's player
icon is that this yeah
soldier all right we're not previewing
each individual thing we got we got a
lot to get through but i got some good
sprays uh we'll have to get into your
spray game here look at that skin a
little later all right that's pretty
cool sure i'll put that one on yeah i'll
probably have a better one later
hopefully here's hoping all right let's
go box number three
more blue
geez really come on give yourself a
beard at least just you your player icon
is generic overwatch all right go on
there we go
what's next
box four
all right how many boxes is this gonna
take for us to get something other than
a blue it's been four
uh of sprays
oh three blues okay now we're feeling a
little better you got yourself a little
widowmaker rose skin all right that's a
small difference but uh kind of nice i
mean i've already got the really cool
one you get with the collector's edition
the the other one oh look i got some
currency i'm up to 50. i'll pay you back
here we go
what are we number six
oh
soldier in the white jacket now does
this make you more visible i don't think
so there are some skins that you kind of
feel like that's that's that's making a
bigger target of yourself oh i like both
these skins spray the sprays that one's
pretty cool
yep cute four for four and up box love
it all right next one
come on give me some yellows damn blues
oh
next is that a currency icon i think so
oh here we go here we go here we go oh
baby you got a pound got a bunch of
currency and a good looking symmetra
skin not the best symmetra skin but
that's all right not the best but man
symmetra is the best i love symmetra all
right what else we got here
louie back on them blues oh
winston what are you fancy here danny
take your pick i mean i thought probably
banana
banana it is it is on theme it is a
little bit more peanut butter winston
that's pretty good all right we'll go
for that one look at this
casual may she's just chilling just
casual just reading her readouts
oh well that's perfect for you welcome
to the gun show
i love that yeah
classic games
what we got here oh yeah yes sir dude
get it that zenyatta
like it freeze
it's so good oh my god i only took 10
boxes but we got a goodie
oh the glowing the flames the like giant
feather on top that's great
that looks wonderful that's good i'm
gonna use this one too that's a good
diva all right a little creepy because
she has no eyes
fox 11.
nope swinging a miss oh i got a
duplicate so i got five is five all they
give you welcome to the gun show
it's a terrible accident sorry folks
next stop
blues blues blues more gold
that's yeah i like that one yeah you do
you do play fair enough that you should
get a different spray
yeah i gotta say the first after you
know getting a bunch of sprays in beta
having a generic spray just depresses me
now ooh what's this oh highlight intro
up up away look at the dumb face she has
on hey i'm the healer
all right you gotta do it though yeah
that's pretty good victory pose
casual i couldn't even tell if that was
the non-generic one i think what's the
generic when he crosses his oh yeah
purple purple pants
sure i can go what's this that's a spray
torbjorn's like ikea schematic
that's great using that yeah you take
your hammer you take five scrap or you
know five hits
oh another per not a victory oh that's a
skin right oh it is yeah it's like a oh
a little bit of softer color a little
bit more gray i'll do it for that thank
you oh that's a cool one i love these
other things what are those things they
have a massive one of these in the
blizzard office when i was there two
months ago i feel like pretty funny i
want if they have a massive one of those
i want it to be squishy so you can like
jump on it yeah it is
the one they had was oh make a massive
flush yes please
hate when the purple ends up being gold
don't do that you're not gonna hit it
when you can buy a sweet skin at the end
of this uh opening situation
folks if you're just joining us we are
in the middle of opening 51 loot boxes
back to back to back to back to back and
uh so far got some got i think the
highlight so far has maybe for me been
that zenyatta skin yeah uh we got the
freed skin just a moment ago
uh and a ton of sprays we're not really
delving into spray situation right now
how many we got a running total on all
the skins we got so far probably like
like seven or eight
you know what uh we can no i have not
been keeping track all right we'll put
something on that in my hand and paper
here but they're like a counter on this
yeah we're tally it up i got some so i'm
up to almost 500 gold as well
of course this did cost 40 dollars just
to just
we've we have 33 to go
oh my god so i've already spent like
lunch for the rest of the week i guess
how worth it will it be hey what's up
roadhog thumbs up just hanging out i
never noticed that he had the uh
his brass knuckles say left
on his left hand oh yeah to do just so
you can keep track maybe he's
left-handed oh there's a green mercy i
like that one equip
all right another box
we have yet to get the gold
legendary we've had some purples yes
that's true but
no gold yet and we are about uh 20 boxes
deep whoa okay keep going then i guess
starting to see some duplicates uh
sprays
another purple we're not even halfway
here oh we got a little mccree
bamf
highlight intro what's that badass
mother effer so for when yes it is nice
it is indeed
i like it
azuki i like the bean ooh look at this
i love it my favorite thing about this
is that i'm going to be like a level
four player with all these skins so many
everyone's gonna know yep everyone's
gonna know what i did the dirty thing i
did
sure
sure i'll use that spray what so you
know what's happened can i just tell you
what's happening oh the intro there's
this horrible thing has happened chris
where
i i'm unlocking all these boxes but
what's actually happened is that now the
feeling of opening a loot crate means
nothing to me oh he's dead inside it's
like he's gonna have to get another 40
like next week right like it like i feel
like when i earn one of these it's gonna
be like oh whatever
yeah it'll take a while for this the
thrill to wear off you are binging
that's a pretty cool thing that's cool i
like that one that's cooler than the
white and it's got this this teeth on
the mouth oh yeah like the skull
yum yum oh that's good all right got
some more gold out of that one some good
purple skins where is that gold gonna
come from
i feel like i've gotten this one 12
times like i get it i wonder if it's
gone up the duplicate like now it's plus
15.
like if because you've gotten it so many
times it like that's becomes more
valuable uh we've reached over the
halfway point chris
we're over at the halfway point let's
still chugging along we've got a a
decent amount of purples uh but no gold
yet
let's hope that the second half is a bit
better than the first one a little more
productive yeah more bluey's steady
stream of blues big tracer poster up to
740 i think by the time we're done with
this you'll have at least a grand uh to
buy that whatever elite skin you want oh
you mean winston yeah oh you mean safari
winston absolutely 100 safari winston
every time you're not going for purp
zarya
that's all right
we'll get a better zarya maybe that's a
that looks awful that looks like
somebody made this in adobe fireworks
macromedia i'll be using that what about
this no like water sure why not huh life
is pain he has a different take on it
than uh
they have a different philosophical uh
no
grounding
different schools of thought yeah oh
that's a cool one little green lemon
lime diva i mean every diva is cool
because they're so big yep and like so
the color change is like so it has a
bigger impact visually yeah oh here we
go coming on the perp pipe
money money money money
i like that one emerald this looks like
a beetle
yeah it does like a diva does have those
like insect skins oh the gold what's it
gonna be
oh ooh a little duplicate two in a row
look at the gold one
soldier 76 night ops oh his face you can
see it doesn't have the eye thing his
eyes have other things his hair is
slightly receding dog tags are jangling
i love that we're up to 905 in dough as
well
this is almost almost worth the
investment almost almost
look at that look at this not this is
another
like macromedia fireworks skin all right
right here we are
we are currently i think at two golds as
the chad pointed out that zenyatta skin
was gold okay that was not a perfect uh
so
i do like to i do like the junk ready
look i just got the overwatch logo
basic logo not basic enough for you now
add the words to literally tell people
what you're spraying man this is cool i
like jailbreak jailbird looks like the
joker a bit or something in this one
that's a pretty cool may one two oh my
god
oh i don't
i don't know about it danny
i don't know it looks like a fat baby
roadhog but it's also supposed to be a
pig oh
dude again yeah doopy doops i didn't
realize that books can you apply book
spray to everyone and just become like a
warrior for literacy it's just winston
yeah exactly every time you kill someone
just put a reading stamp on them we got
15 of our 51
boxes
this one again how many times do i gotta
be for the horde all right it looks like
it's not increasing 55 credits every
time you're getting a duplicate getting
a lot of duplicates i'll just say that
getting a lot of duplicates right now oh
i like that victory folks yeah pretty
cool hoist that fusion gun thing plasma
there we go 50 so we're actually over we
went over already excellent so we can
buy it got the money we can consider the
purchase a little later on
stream uh-oh another gold whoa
much gold wow whole hunk
yeah we might have a sec we might have
enough for a second i get two two elites
sure let's use that
which beat will i use with bastion today
i really want to get into my beeps
goals yeah look at this one
she's doing a little love thing she has
a heart emote that like draws a
pixelated heart on the screen oh yeah
and then it and it evaporates it's
really cool i paid for that one go gold
oh
oh my god this is some straight up star
wars the lion heart oh that is good that
is so awesome look at his knuckles his
knuckles he's got the claws man it looks
like he's stepped out of stormwind and
you can see his saddled man face yeah
look with his little scar and his dirty
eye
nice work equip equip yep i'll be
keeping that one that's cool hey what up
victory pose sure confident confident i
would describe lucio as confident yes oh
my god ronnie what is it 220 shy of a
second one
come on papa wants a brand new skin
you got one i mean i mean did you see
the last one i got his wish sorry dude
you want to go back to like the old navy
version
when he can't see his face
once you see his face
there's like
mud oh i guess his pants are dirty sure
you sure whatever look at this spray i
like that one mercy it's pretty good
just put that over anyone else's spray
that you ever see
well like shut down let's see that oh
we've only got eight of these left
our loot box marathon is coming to a
close
the end is in sight danny
does not care about zarya skins in the
least nope you can tell how much i play
zarya
oh here we go here we go purple purple
oh that's that's some straight matrix is
overwhelming
overwhelming that's his uh best uh keanu
reeves impression yeah right there
positively well
six boxes
nope you want to rock your widow
swinging him
icon
oh so many greys so many sprays so many
dupes we're uh oh we might not do it we
need a hundred hours
65 we're gonna do it four boxes left
folks to get to the 2k
so you can get a couple of skins um
another roadhog one he's got purple
pants now right thistle sure that makes
sense thistle three left
oh i just got a hundred
it just popped up i got a hundred i'm
telling you we're gonna make it see
cha-ching so i get 150 so i guess the
the gold counter if you look on the top
right you can see it pop up before
before oh
you only need 15 more or like one dupe
if i am shy of 50 i'm gonna be so
disappointed so the next box is the last
box that we purchased that we paid for
and then the next one after that is one
that i earned with my own by leveling up
to level four okay cross your fingers
can we hold hands chris can we hold
hands yeah all right let's hold hands
we're holding hands so warm in here so
damp okay let me do this
here we go here we go
yes
yeah over two grand pushed over the top
all right counting
two grabs so there you go the exchange
rate is 40 dollars to 2035.
so that's everything we got out of the
50 loot crates um let's just open the
one i earned yeah because this one was
all you danny it's gonna pop a legendary
isn't it as you can just tell it's gonna
come
down it's gonna be like eight sprays yep
and a symmetra line and
precisely yep all right why not
precisely there you go
so we came at it out with uh oh yeah
what's the tally let's go let's just
take a look at the hero gallery real
quick all right sure just like go back
let's see the general numbers okay
because you're pretty much at zero for
most of these pretty much right i had a
couple of sprays and stuff but that was
about so genji and roadhog were the big
winners in terms of uh physics specific
items whereas mccree's in the basement
with four
uh everyone's got new things but i think
our big wins were uh the zenyatta and
reinhardt skins yes for sure let's go to
zenyatta oh we got that look at that
skin it's the only skin we got for him
yeah it's probably the best skin there
so good i mean i do also like the yeah
the
the horus head
uh
but the afridis dope uh which other ones
were good reinhardt was the lion heart
skin oh yeah mine heart rhino look at
that that like blue glow
his other ones are
oh that's stone one's pretty dope
actually yeah the stone is also i'll
take that one over it but uh yeah sure
solid solid uh which other ones were
good we got a see like fair is my go-to
for instance and for her i got
uh oh i got the security chief one i
didn't realize well that's because you
purchased oh my god
so this is the only one that i got
um which is pretty good does she have i
mean she has some other ones that are
pretty cool got some sprays for her too
yup that's pretty cool probably go for
this one here um and then let's see my
other one i play a lot of is widowmaker
let's just see her real quick yeah you
got two skins here you got the rose and
the
ciel oh yeah the rose one is yeah noir
is the one that you get for the the
pre-purchase um for the
for for pre-purchasing overwatch so i
guess that was that one um but yeah some
of my right ones i mean even like i feel
like i got a skin for everyone
the best games the best thing though is
that we have now two thousand gold to
spend on anything we want that's true so
i can get any of these hot look at that
do you have a skin in mind or do you
want to maybe come back in the stream
later and spend your money i want all of
these skins look at all these dumb ass
kids look how dumb this game is i mean
the one i really want every time
is safari winston because it's just
because there's two actually right there
yeah you go undersea
under yeah the pith helmet
i think and the mustache look at that so
good that's amazing
that's probably the one i like you've
been talking about a lot why not pull
the trigger on it should i i already
bought it look at these though these are
cool too whoa
for a firearm oh that's incredible that
native american pacific northwest look i
think i need to go for the ones i play
the most yes so you're gonna get the
most out of it i'm gonna buy this yeah
dude i'm gonna buy this look at that i
mean i didn't even get a skin for her
anyway
you did you got so you got like an
emerald green oh yeah i don't care about
it but no you know i'm irish and i don't
care about that so who else
security chief is alright look at that
look at that yes that's so good and then
i guess
let me put
let me put the trigger on the other one
the winston safari
you don't want to do it yet just just
just let it marinate okay i'll get yeah
i'm going to let them out they're going
to think about it but to be honest this
is probably the one who this right here
the the like bird masquerade looking
this is like some assassin's creed
syndicate nonsense that definitely is
i'm going to go probably this one
i don't even know what to say about that
that's just that's nsfw right there but
we'll see that for another day so
feathery thank you so much for watching
if you're watching this on the map thank
you so much for watching the video of us
opening all these things that cost me 40
do you decide for yourself whether or
not it was worth it for you
uh should we play we should play all
right let's get in let's get back to it
do you think it was worth it
i don't necessarily think that was worth
40 i don't think so
nope i'm gonna go ahead and say no
should we buy another one
i know
our evidence is pretty limited
one 40 purchase is not enough to
evaluate you know for sure whether
it's really we need a bigger statistical
sample i mean that's just good science i
know because we're just trying to do you
right here we need the sample size needs
to be bigger i think we definitely need
to log in on my account and then do that
that's a good check all right hopefully
should we stop after a while as well so
you can hop in on here you've played
like two matches keep going keep on
rocking my man we're gonna go here for
a little while we're going to play up
until
um another hour and a quarter which will
bring us up until noon specific then mr
mike mahari who is reviewing overwatch
is going to come in and play a bunch
himself and then we've got the lobby at
two o'clock better than two hours after
that oh my god like i just want to be
reinhardt now it's just right there you
are attacking at volskaya
you'll have a chance to play them all
yeah overwatch is out now we're living
in a post-overwatch world
okay dope she looks
okay how tough she looks so freaking
cool
ah but all right so what are those like
tails of because you know the feathers
are from birds but what are those tails
from on your shoulders are those like
wolf tails or is that like because it
looks it looked furry oh yeah these guys
it doesn't look like a hair braid that
she's just covered in a bunch of dead
animals yeah stone
listen let's try not to overthink it
hey everyone check out my skin check it
out
oh yeah they're admiring you can always
tell when people are are admiring your
skins
which is like a real weird thing to say
in normal life but makes totally good
sense in video game land now i feel like
a cosplayer this is what it's like when
you go to pax and you're all dolled up
in some dope ass costume yes you can
take a picture
yes five dollars five dollars everyone
let me just uh you know put down my big
gulp
that's right
mercy emoting giving some props
i have a question for you danny sure
on this emote wheel right i see people
sometimes say
you know on the the text it'll say
so-and-so wants to attack the point
right how do you get that to come up i
think you look at the point and then say
do you say group up do you have to be
looking at the point
i don't know i have to be on the point
maybe like you want to defend or attack
the point you choose group up and you're
on the point i actually don't know we
should probably check that out we'll see
if chat can uh give us the answer here
hey christopher robin thanks for
watching uh catch you later my man
oh no we're getting how are we getting
ganked so hard already oh reaper you're
gonna
he's gonna die he's gonna do boom
out of here jerk
straight into the drink
yeah oh
shadow step your way out of that one
yeah it's not all that bad he gets to
look at my sweet skin and the death
replay yeah he does it's really a treat
for your enemies oh doctor oh you're
[ __ ] you're a terrible widowmaker what
up
hey buddy oh what's up torbjorn you want
up here on your own you wanna like wanna
1v1 me in a hall something tells me you
put his turret right here
that
don't worry strong counter
stop discording us oh terrible terrible
time to reload donnie that's all right
he got him no he didn't quite get him
oh tracers in there how did this happen
how did we lose this spot come on guys
the objective everyone else you're
you're still capping even though you're
oh you got it nice work nice work i
think you're floating above i think i
might have knocked him off the ground
yeah much as it was uh looks like zarya
back there well she can stay back there
if she wants because we just got the
point eat it
escorted you
oh no
technical problems yeah sorry it's
coming back in a second hdmi cables
underneath their themes sorry team
should be [ __ ] maybe get some zip
ties up in there we go here we go
we're back
look at that somebody just put a
it's just a metro turret just just
testing it out just gonna make sure that
this is uh okay here
kill that venom mine
i guess she knows where i am now whoops
just right by the spawn
oh that
you're getting the kotov no steed
oh get that help
yeah you're in trouble now tracer
eat it tracer you gotta know where the
med packs are
map i need uh i need healing i need
healing i need healing
yeah mercy's on the case
very responsive
all right let's get in there and drop a
dirty old
just like sneak through a doorway it's
my favorite way to do it
yes i wish i could speak french
oh
moose
just
ah
you just ruined reinhardt's charge yeah
i mean
molten core oh oh mercy's taking some
taking some hits off that one oh things
about to blow up
guns oh here we
go uh his name's genji actually not
donezo
you're the worst widowmaker ever
zarya is doing a pretty good job with
these projected shields i'm just
capturing the point on my own
solo solo shoot oh i almost had her
almost had her
finally talked enough [ __ ] to the
widowmaker i know to get widowmade
i got a widow made
i got so widow-made i almost had it i'll
fire it up that's a pain in the butt uh
we've got an observation in the twitch
chat from siege to wonder if it's weird
that i feel too much anxiety at playing
games like this so instead i just watch
other people play for the whole day i
can totally appreciate that i had the
same problem with team fortress 2 for
the longest time oh my goodness yes that
game would freak me the hell out just
because i always felt like i was not
with it in that game yes i know owned
what i understand the basics and even
like advanced tactics but like that so
bleeding edge the tactics nuanced in
that that game
yeah i definitely feel the like
intimidation factor for real that's a
yeah i i can appreciate that i mean i
maybe play against some bots a little
while yeah i'm gonna try and get in here
and kill widowmaker because i feel like
she's flanked she's like
messing around with everyone back here
i also think that with overwatch you
know they're
because you can pick a character you
know the characters only have a few
different things they can do it's pretty
easy to dial in the basics and then be
effective you know you don't have to be
getting plays of the game or anything
like that you know you can just be sort
of an effective if you're playing the
role that your
character is meant to play then oh sugar
it's cool
oh no we're not sorry i thought we were
still i thought we were on camera
okay it's okay danny everything's cool
just watch the widowmaker you were
talking smack about play the game
we don't make it get played again oh no
this is the
wait yes this is the enemy
oh the one side is your allied widow
maker actually i think
oh yeah yeah nice work
39 i mean i ain't bad i'll give it to
the healer she was she sorted me out 30
of team damage taken yeah i just you
know like i like reading that stat and
thinking about how much worse it would
have gone if
my team had taken x percent more damage
right and because that trend what does
that translate to you know that it
like defeating a push uh you know
choking people at a point just that much
longer like choking people out i like
that yeah it's different video game it's
but yeah you're right it's yeah like how
does that sort of translate back into
to it depends i guess on where that
damage came from is kind of the thing
yeah
all right earlier conversation uh
cynthia here at gamespot weighing in
with it helps if you play with a buddy
because there are a couple characters
that like work really well paired up and
uh you know if you that's one of the
keys to sort of just filling your role
is supporting your teammates so
you know if you're if you're lucio and
you're just hanging out by most of where
your teammates are and staying alive
you're doing work you're doing it god
who should i be
basically yeah your team has the roles
covered at this point so i mean defend
is a is a fun time to like experiment
with different
two mercies what do you think about that
i like diva should you go for two tanks
to match your two mercies
yeah why not maybe winston
winston winston
oh you get to work that banana skin and
see if you uh feel like you want that
safari upgrade all about that banana
yeah let's see i mean he looks pretty
cool
doing a solid thing you got a solid
winston situation all right mercy you
want to go for a ride mercy let's do it
boom
almost did she come with you
yup looks like she did all right you got
a good one
damage boosted winston is like a i don't
know that seems like a real good
good player to damage specifically
because of the his gun doesn't do a ton
of
like i feel like his gun doesn't do a
ton of direct burst damage or anything
like that right it's like a slow eating
away but if you amp that up a little bit
then
it seems like it'd be a real problem oh
look at this beautiful dance
so the thing is right i think they're
doing the wrong thing by going up here
because yeah the last team did that and
we basically got through the choke point
here yeah super quick you really
should not engage that so i'm not that
far out yeah i'm gonna ask them to group
up here because like they're just if
they get killed
i mean that's also not the best place
for this it probably should be a little
bit maybe in here a bit
but whatever
i'm not gonna see how it goes
you guys did did pretty solid job
pushing last time you're pretty well
matched but you know even one different
player can change the composition and
yeah you see two of your players are
already down
this is danny's sort of jump in uh he's
gonna find some health back there
so but you can still
i don't know if this is a good fight
but you got him now you get a leap back
to safety oh almost made it yeah i wish
my healer came with me she was
keeping the turret man alive for some
reason
can you damage boost a turret i don't
think you can yeah i mean he's not gonna
cause much damage anyway so
because it's one of the maps
i feel like
is this one of the only maps that the
you know the objective does not res well
i guess it's two successive objectives
it's not a payload map and it's not a
single attack point type map so get on
the point
chris realizing obvious things about
overwatch
folks if you're just joining us thanks
for coming by welcome to the overwatch
stream chris waters here commentating
while daniel dwyer plays as his winston
in the banana skin uh i don't think
bananas technically the name of it but
melted that reaper nicely it is bananas
uh we're streaming here on all sorts of
places youtube facebook twitch
game spot if you if you've joined us in
those mediums please like and subscribe
uh you know we got a lot of awesome
overwatch content already up on site
we've got a bunch of guides coming down
the pipe we're about halfway through
doing the whole roster and that's a
great way that's a great place for
people you know we were talking earlier
about uh sort of
a team a team strategy game like this
can feel uh high pressure you know you
want to fulfill your role you want to do
right by your team
watch a little guide and then they're
like they're like five minutes and
they're not too in-depth you know we
don't we're not talking about like
esports level strategies we're just
talking about the basic stuff you need
to do and a few little tricks to to help
you do it
uh so check those out there on youtube
and uh yeah thanks for joining us here
as danny and his team standing pretty
strong on the first point the
enemy team managed to get the first
third of the cap down but now they're
sort of beaten back past the checkpoint
give your buddy a little help with the
genji oh
there i think it was
uh oh creeper is
being bossy again
telling people to die wrong side to
reload danny that was
a really unfortunate reload yeah that
was bad oh
my poor danny
mercy was off healing
reaper again
i guess reinhardt was there maybe she
got killed by that
that's a shame um
ah there it goes that's how it happens
so quick i shouldn't have jumped off the
point that time probably
should have let them cap just a little
more guys you wanna
wanna push up a little bit
widowmaker get up there do you like to
engage past this choke point not
necessarily i mean it depends who you're
with i guess
depends who you are if i'm winner maker
i'll sit up there yeah
but uh no this is kind of where you want
to be i feel good
all
right is that ferris in trouble here
get higher than fair again oh going for
the hill oh she got it
but i think you're you managed to absorb
at least one of her rockets
nice chase nice chase
oh berserker barrage
he wants to punch that reaper off the
cliff so bad
reaper alt against winston alt
and it's winston alt for the win and
mercy with some clutch healing just then
and good escape work by danny yeah
hopefully live another day
well she's not well he's getting people
in a site so i might as well just sit
back here for a little hot second is
that ours speaking of which danny
banting 43 is wondering about uh do a
little do a little hero tip session live
for winston you know we've we've put
together winston vid uh but the tactics
here are like winston as a tank
is uh
he's a hit-and-run kind of tank yes for
sure you do not want him to be you know
waiting up there like a reinhardt just
trying to spray everyone you come across
yeah he's kind of like
shock and awe like you want to jump in
on you want to pounce on like uh
individuals as much as you can you know
what i mean
so for him that's kind of what his
shield is about it's able to isolate one
person around him it's not necessarily
to protect his health
oh
what happened there my jump just died
that was weird did you maybe hit the
step that you jumped up on
so you've got a genji in the back there
but so yeah it's he's got this
oh there we go genji alt yeah he can't
dodge my uh
yeah genji can't deflect your your
lightning and your lighting doesn't it
doesn't have to be aimed oh sugar you
got me the last second yeah
that was good but you got the you got
some good mercy heels although i think
your mercy just died so yeah be careful
be careful
i'm going to try to get up in there on
this soldier oh
oh another reaper spit roasted
yeah he's definitely in isolation kind
of you jump in on someone you zap them
with the lightning a little bit then you
pop the shield and the shield is to not
protect you from the person you're
actively engaging it's to you know
because you'll attract attention from
the enemy team they will start firing on
you your shield is ideally going to buy
you a little bit of time free from that
fire and then you know like on in this
engagement genji stepped outside through
his shurikens and they didn't hit and so
that's a way for you to
deny that fire while you're engaging uh
his ult is a different thing this is
something you want to use to like
just mix things up i did a really bad
job there i didn't really know you're
going to do it yep
oh you see cracked through the ice there
that was pretty good yeah i did a bad
job in adults the alt is kind of again
used for
crack through
that's pretty good uh is used for
spreading people out as much as you can
like you shouldn't really use it to like
that lucio was near a reinhardt you
don't want them hanging out together so
trying to punch him trying to leap
around and punch uh some of them away is
better you know we saw
we saw danny fight a reaper with uh and
they both altered and danny barely
escaped his life but he won but like
that's the one-on-one thing is not
really what uh
winston's fault excels at somebody needs
to take this goddamn genji out that
genji is pretty vexing
and uh looks like you've got some
reinhardts on the points
yeah and they
they pop the lucio alt
so your may just denied you access
you're gonna wanna
oh yeah jump jump from above
shut out that soldier fire focus down on
lucio nicely done gonna alt now didn't
get the kill on yusio did get the kill
on lucio yes
oh it's kind of hard to keep track of
what you're doing but hey when soldier
76 is all frozen
you can punch him in the face real good
nicely done
danny them up a little bit that was a
good little alt pushback of their uh
push on the point and they were most of
the way towards the second
third of capture
and uh you denied it to them he's dead
too saved may who got knocked on her
butt there
y2ken chiming in winston is great at
distracting the enemy from your team's
actual damage dealers because he's so in
your face that's true people think that
people want to like get rid of him as
quickly as possible because he's such a
hassle yes he's so imposing and so scary
and i think
they sort of uh
especially in these kind of early pop
you know early games where everyone's
still figuring it out i feel like he's
uh
he can be a massive hassle on people
oh widowmaker
you
are in a bad spot
i got her oh no no she went up
this is not a place i want to be yeah
getting
all right well fortunately they they
disengaged and now you can
almost jump down on his head
doesn't work dude yeah he pops the
deflect but uh you're not deflecting
winston's zippity zaps
thank you oh she missed me she just
missed me to finish me off xps insane we
did open the loot boxes earlier on but
uh if you missed it we'll be breaking
that out and uh posting it to site going
through 50 loot boxes plus one to grow
on and uh
seeing what the results of that were
that's got some good stuff not sure if
it's totes worth it but oh that was cool
your barrier came all the way or back
around is she here these moving
platforms are i feel like they're unique
to volskaya industries and they're
definitely a
strange
kind of tactical consideration yeah
sometimes you see a bastion sitting up
on it almost super weird it's so
annoying same as that elevator in
hollywood they just kind of
yeah the elevators in hollywood yep
that torbjorn's love to put a turret on
that first hollywood point
so you can do a little bit of flanking
with him as well because you can jump
yeah just make sure you line it up and
now you're gonna come from an unexpected
angle
and
punch tiny diva far away but get on the
point yeah because
they you need to stay on this point
because they are all on it
and you have no teammates oh nice
you hopefully your team is going to be
there in a second because you are like
dead oh they are contesting
but it's not going to be good you should
probably get back on there nice yup oh
almost
how did that i guess the genji gotcha
i guess that genji was ulting oh nice oh
hey now
god i love a well-timed resurrect
there's there's not much better pop that
shield save our asses
this genji has been giving you guys
problems really good at evading he's
doing damage and then he's dashing out
and just like using the map yep getting
the health
causing probs
stay with me
there you go
widowmaker trying to take that point so
low it's not gonna happen you're going
down babe one health one health one oh
yowza overtime's burning down the point
is contested i need a healer i need a
heater i can't go out there
yeah
i know you should
yeah there's no i needed a heater or i
needed a bubble oh there was no way i
would have lasted throw your life on the
point danny nah give it all for
overwatch i just wanted the the bubble
that's all i thought that was a good
game that was a tough
uh
tough push at the end there
even with the uh
the alt oh my mercy to keep you guys in
the game
okay reaper
all right fine so good
oh you killed three people i got killed
with an alt it's not that good was it i
don't know
thanksgioder healing power all right
i'll play one more and then we'll swap
over to you
yeah all right that work yeah
yeah because i like to play different
characters than you like to play so i
see a little variety
eric variety ooh did i get new loot box
let's open it let's open it quick let's
open it quick let's see if we can open
it quick let's leave the game
loot box baby
yeah an extra five for that spray
menacing
as opposed i think his last one was what
casual
that's casually reaper's pretty menacing
like all the time i want to see one of
my hot
plays what did they think your pharah
hot play was
hot dripping plays
come on come on
it'll be cool if somebody's gonna mod
this game so this thing also says play
of the game so people can like export
them and feel really good about it look
at that oh so good such a good skin such
a good sturdy skin oh yeah knock this
guy off the edge this is the best part
to get watch this
he got his health he's coming back
you're in the drink pal
really that was my play of the game
that's pathetic that's really bad okay
let's get back they do i feel like they
do give weight to uh
ring out deaths to like environmental
deaths because like uh
right
like uh you know you blast someone in
the face with a rocket shore but you
gotta have a little more finesse and a
little more situational awareness to get
the ring out and uh yeah definitely as
lucio one of my i got like the highlight
card at the end and it was like three
environmental deaths because i had
bounced some people into a hole in
illios oh that's i've never done that
i've always wanted to pull that one off
it's so good all right i might go for
fire or widowmaker here
i do like my widow
and those oh we've already got a what
are these dreads i don't understand them
i'm gonna go for her because we've
already got a
i just want to get play the game with
her in that dope ass
skin yeah all i want that's i mean it's
good to have goals
i wish look at the face on her like i
wish that on this screen you could click
and like slide left and right to spin
the character model around
i'm gonna go up here none of you jerks
and get up here ha ha these video games
are all mine
we got lost vikings yeah four what is
the tv's adventure a reference to and
blizzard
i don't know
vv
siege mode siege mode it's like uh that
is
a
metal slug yeah
uh soul stone it's like a
golden axe or is it like a hearthstone
samurai showdown
situation yup yeah they're so cool i
love this thing
hey guys okay i'm playing with you now
fighters of the storm
it's pretty good oh yeah tychus interior
kerrigan daniel let's take a quick
moment here to give a shout out to paxon
1889.
it's his birthday happy birthday happy
birthday to you hope someone got you
overwatch
some hot loot boxes uh ricky guitarist
tells us vivi's adventure is a nod to
bonk's adventure yes because he's got
the big dome and he's rocking around but
but when's vivi what's the vba ref oh
we've already got some hot sight lines
on these jerks hey what up i'll push you
over there how do you like that how do
you like that oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
they don't like it danny
the people have spoken
no likey
i need health
some health oh doctor damn it
oh look at my gun even my rockets like
when you drop it yes
it's weird because it looks like it's a
native american thing yep where she's
like egyptian yeah so i feel like
they've just gone hey look there's that
ethnic lady let's just give her a thing
i feel like it's yeah i don't know right
because like you definitely have sort of
these cross-cultural
uh things like
but then there's widowmaker you know
she's got those kind of uh victorian
you know french-looking
couture outfits uh so that's a little
bit more on
sort of message as uh
but then again you've got why am i even
getting involved in this fight you've
got zenyatta in the egyptian
get-ups and what i don't know what the
nationality is zenyatta it's like a i
guess it's it's more of a oh here are
some of the cultures we haven't featured
yeah let's try to represent the kind of
styles of all these different
different cultures yo guys i think we
have the point uh looks like we should
we should get on the point blasted on
his
capturing i like that name blasted
knight that's pretty good
oh
oh i wasn't sitting on the point for a
second whoa let's just do that
i love this because now they've just
spent all that time running out here
oh
time to yeah the the second stage push
on this map can be so effective if you
just race of course that roadhog took
the took a wrong turn what happened
there uh it's a enemy reaper altered it
looked like and then uh was around three
people that just killed him instantly
i'm hoping none of these guys have set
up
proper turrets yet because yeah because
this is going to happen
sitting up on this roof is so oh
someone's got the wolf hunts for its
prey that genji
skin
jerks oh mercy why did you go up there
do you think mercy hit that that chase
uh
ability to follow and then with saw you
altering it was just like whoops yeah
it's too late to stop her trajectory hey
guys you want to actually get on the
point we might have this are you on the
point up there
oh oh oh oh problems problems
molten core is that thing gonna turn and
get you oh it was still a stage one so
it did not go to stage three yeah that's
a torbjorn fun fact you can you throw
down a turret it's a stage one turret
it's real uh easy to throw down doesn't
take any extra energy
but if you molten core it won't upgrade
to the full on juiced up
turret unless it's already level two
so sometimes you need to pop the molten
core so that you yourself can get the
health boost and the damage boost but uh
other times you might wanna you're gonna
wanna save it how have i not been killed
hello that's an enemy
i actually accidentally hit that button
you didn't even get the two too healthy
that whole time
she's louise
yeah i i tried to hit the button for her
yeah
the watcher called the concussive blast
and accidentally absolutely altered but
i'll take it that feeling when
you alt accidentally sorry you guys got
plenty of time
yeah i mean the best part of doing of
sitting up on that back area there is
that everyone's terrified so they don't
run out so it can't it just creates this
constant like slow effect for them where
they're kind of scared yeah and that's a
that's a real important part of mobility
as a as a hero heroes like tracer and
genji and pharah who can like get behind
enemy lines it's not just because you
can come at them from angles they might
not otherwise be expecting did i get him
i almost knocked him off oh almost but
it's also because you
force them to play on their back feet a
little bit more
you force them to pull back from a choke
point you know even if you know you're
not going to cap the point just
something about seeing that like points
being captured will make everyone run
back from maybe a chokepoint that they
are effectively holding i feel like our
sniper could be doing a way better job
in this game
that's like that's one of those things
you sort of get a sense for as you play
more overwatch right is when
uh there's a role that's like not quite
pulling its weight yeah like i feel like
there should be a little bit more sniper
deaths like i might hear yeah like i
might i might go with a maker because
when i whenever i look in here there's
like so many people including a goddamn
turret just sitting there yeah it's like
no we should be dealing with that that's
yeah i just edged that turret but then
you got a hanzo
all right upgrade it don't go around
that corner dan you have 15 health and
it's molten core
he did it anyways and it worked out good
get off my point oh gosh okay
oh look we've already someone else has
already gone widowmaker because our
sniper is doing such a sugary job
i know someone's just gone far out what
the hell are you guys doing you ain't
got no tank all right let me go come on
let's see that let's see that reinhardt
skin that's so annoying because i know
i'd be a better sniper than these jerks
probably
i'm not a good team player chris
danny you know you're trying to help out
you switch to a tank that's okay
you're not on chat you're not telling
them i'm a better sniper than all you
jerks we don't have
is there a turret back there there is
okay one of the three snipers kill that
turret
he thinks if he yells louder they'll
somehow hear him
kill the turret sniper snipes snips
there just to be specific oh my god
you're such noobs did you kill this
the frustration is real
it's so annoying it's so annoying
all right let's finish off that thing
don't just freeze it and stand there
i'm not sure if the barrier helps but i
think i might have
the mecca is back and she's got mercy
healing so you probably i mean i guess
you're keeping them off the point which
is good because your team is currently
pushing the point yeah well now they
have regrouped and found themselves
i might want to go in this nook together
wow
this is not a good place to be nope
i'll just go on the other side of this
every time
all right
i'm going to go slide back that is such
an effective
audio cue the like drastic inhale of
breath it makes you feel wounded you
know you're wounded and low on health i
think that's one of the one of the
really nice things about overwatch is
that specific queue of course it doesn't
happen every time because sometimes you
just get flat out killed but
all right let's see if danny can be the
difference maker i mean
his widowmaker and hanzo have failed him
and
he
wants to show them how it's done yeah
see widowmaker there see done widowmaker
your job can i show you how to do your
job teach me how to snipe you can you
teach me see hanzo now he's watching his
arse
we got diva up there getting killing
people for free push them back push them
back way
back
thanks chris yeah little american
cheerleader cheer for you there danny
this is dumb i would not usually push
this far forward but i can see this is
happening
okay well she's got it now oh no we have
it
got a question in the twitch chat from
cdn killjoy do you think it would be
benefit the game if there could only be
one of a character at a time uh like
rainbow succeed no uh
danny's a hard no on that that had that
is a uh a variant mode they had during
beta you cannot you could only play as
one of each uh and i think it definitely
you know
oh doctor
problems
ah i'm not playing well either he's so
angry
uh if you guys don't have a tank do you
think like a reinhardt pushing in would
help or would that just get totally torn
up
i think we might have it now as long as
they can hold in some of those kills at
the back
no one is on the point no one can hide
reaper is halting and killing two or
three of your dudes
is that a that's the torbjorn back there
say goodbye to your precious little
turret
keep an eye you're out folks also when
you are playing for footsteps if you
hear someone's footsteps that are kind
of heavy footfalls that means the person
is real danger to you that's going to be
like a
uh reaper or a mccree and that's going
to cause you problems so if you hear
heavy footfalls by the way you can get
and you can get away really quick if you
use that uh
if you use that widowmaker yeah the
grappling hook is definitely not just
something for reaching high points for
sniping advantage although it is that
it's also yeah just like a general
mobility thing where you need to uh you
need to get the heck away
then get the heck away
all right get that mercy
or a hanzo
oh diva's coming for you oh
got the healer though
the little venom mine discouraged but
that mercy is just not gonna or that
diva is just not gonna pursue
taking down the tank oh
timely uh whatever that thing is called
deny this is a tough sitch
can you guys get the push
you kill or two and then are you gonna
get in there as widowmaker just get on
the point yep there's an alt that got
one or two
oh then the mercy came with a revive
gonna be the glorious ending you're
hoping for get on the point oh see you
mercy
it's overtime you've got two
kill that turret oh it's molten cord
iced it up
uh
for everyone's watching reaper don't
forget the turrets gonna come uncovered
soon
can you get it down in time
yes yes
yes
there it's down reinhardt's on the point
you just gotta keep
hanzo came around
may is the only one on the point now
lucio's rushing back
i'm not gonna get there
oh and then it's an alt from the enemy
hanzo i'm not sure if it took anyone out
are you gonna feel when i back around
it's the quick burn down it looks like
that's gonna be it oh pretty solid last
push there it was better than i was
expecting i gotta say
um but yeah
tough one
the frustration is real when you uh feel
like your team roles are not being
fulfilled right of course because
you know then you have stuff like
turrets uh just constantly heckling uh
when they should just be easily taken
out by whatever sniper is around yeah
there was just too many snipers and the
turrets were sitting there the whole
time it was just like how are we
supposed to get a tank in there
if
the turret is just sitting pretty
entirely there you go 30 team damage
done thank you blue team what more
you're
i'll vote for myself sometimes you gotta
vote for yourself you know nobody's
gonna have one more game danny let's end
on a good note for you get another game
in i'm so sorry are you gonna ride this
one out uh so you're this maybe defend
on hanamura or they may move you into a
new situation what do you think you're
going to stick with this team we've got
a couple people leaving the voice
channel yeah let's uh i'll do it i'll do
it
i'll do did you play much last night
i got home last night and i installed it
on my playstation and then i oh tay
wants to play
uh maybe we'll get him in on the next
can you invite at this stage let's let's
do oh he's in already let's do it next
time because i'm going to drop out
anyway so you can hop in so
you know we don't want to yeah i'll go
with again uh i basically i fell victim
to that annoyance of the modern console
generation because i was trying to play
it on ps4 where it installed and then i
was like cool i'll play this later but i
didn't turn on the i didn't actually
start the game so i didn't trigger the
secondary install period so
i did not get to play last night instead
i went to bed dreaming of symmetra
turrets
i was worried that you go the other
playstation problem which is you
download this on battlenet and that's
super fast but you download it on
playstation network and it takes forever
yeah
us
forever
diablos x in the twitch chat wants to
know how can danny stand when his back
should hurt so much
watch from putting the team on it oh i
got the team on my back though
on my back though
yeah i like that i don't know i've uh
yeah
i was being a real
i can i can be the world's worst most
annoying teammate
just ask any of my colleagues in the
words of eric today in the chat salt is
real yeah i'm all
can definitely yeah when you're playing
you can definitely get that those chippy
kind of like
i'm impatient with how things are going
you guys should be doing this
differently or better
we're all guilty of that i think that's
exactly where i want that fire to be
yeah just sit right there
actually i should have put that way
further down because it's going to be
too late by the time i know it's
triggered yeah they'll be choking poison
but also blasting you
oh reaper's going to pop his little
creepy face out
oh diva is coming straight for me
i see
the first duel does not go well for
edward he was the health there's two
health stand here so helps back here
puts a little fire on diva making her
think about her actions oh and now in a
little uh one-on-one versus farah
you can land 100 shots it's gonna be
good but uh pharah's got the height
advantage is matter in their house gonna
have to work the health map knowledge
takes a shot at mccree now it's just
everyone is focusing down on the front
line widowmaker yeah maybe i shouldn't
have been that push that far forward the
rest of the team was sitting back they
didn't they had no
interest in keeping them back there i
feel like that's a missed opportunity i
think there was a chance also where you
and maybe instead of going for the
second health could have roped for that
uh
let that little nook to go back behind
the wall in for a penny and for a pound
chris
retreat is also a thing to do sometimes
all right they are on the point
oh get her
oh now you got the suit in there
you got a lot of got a lot of enemy
meets in there oh
god how did they let that happen
come on danny it's a team
you let it happen too
take ownership ah
sorry it's not the best time hey you can
do it bud don't worry uh this is we got
eight minutes on b this is your long
sight line situation this is true this
is this is your snipey town galore
hopefully your symmetra is switching
to a mercy okay yeah uh do you guys have
a tank i don't know who knows
are you giving them the thanks for
switching nice
you're you've always been good with the
the the quick chats and the the emotes i
think
one of your strengths as a player danny
because i don't have my um yeah right
super important because i don't have my
what headset hooked up for anything do
you normally uh play with voice chat on
when you're playing on pc here
[ __ ] that was the only one
really yep um no i don't usually
available because i've got the whole
streaming setup at home so it's a bit
more complicated together yeah usually
it's your voices to the audience
not the
team situation
i kind of nobody likes to be on a team
with someone who's voice chatting to
their twitch audience right while
they're on voice chat she's so excited
this steve is
but just not here
daylight savings time am i right yeah
bst baby oh wow already
that diva is really working that uh
projectile denial thing boom why don't
they call it projectile denial
that was nice that was quite nice
recon assist yeah that zenyatta is yours
eat him up
oh god the recon visor's so good
where's he going he's gone up he's
if you hear that
pass into the shadows and then that
sounded weirdly british yeah that's it
but if you hear that look for that
column of smoke because uh
there's like moments when reaper appears
in those places that he is uh
oh best you can really not take oh god
yeah just
yeah just kind of wait right here
do you think it could kill you past that
barrier i think it probably could
that took a long time to develop
where is she
there you go you found her she missed
she hit the hole
you pointed right at her she was like oh
it doesn't matter i hit this wall yeah
it did
you're dead you did oh
quiet moment in between uh pushes you we
got six minutes left chris we gots this
no problem you got staying power
just keep
chipping away at that diver i can force
her to use that thing down there that's
pretty good i want you to kill that
zenyatta a lot
yeah him and his discord those orbs man
the orb is so powerful
was that a that was that a case of
mccree being like hey my bullet goes far
i could toe to toe with the widowmaker
nah you can it's a bad idea
oh did it hit the lantern
oh get him nice
oh zenyatta's pushing up
you really want that zenyatta oh my god
this i really like playing zenyatta uh
but
i am super annoyed by zenyatta whenever
he's on the other team so you know what
you do you danny it's your match um
is it though
all right looks like he got one with the
high noon nice work
one here you know
oh got him for you baby yeah
ain't you the sweetest
oh
kino midnight nineteen points oh that
junkrat's having a terrible day with me
says
this is a call back to our earlier
question
target objective and press the f key
will shout your defend attack the
objective
there you go yeah there it is
nice thank you the whole team tip the
whole team's like yeah
yeah really widowmaker is that what we
should do yeah understood
thanks
oh i switched to lucio dude i'd love
sniping so good i love slapping so much
it's the best it's really fun
oh good good great this is what he's
doing now eh that's his latest tactic
what little piece he's lobbing him in
because he doesn't want to go anywhere
near me
i mean that's a that's a reason that's a
reasonable junk rat strat especially if
you're waiting for your team to respawn
just throw some bombs in there mix them
up for a second i thought we had an afk
there it was like that would explain it
nope
about to get real mad nothing worse than
the afk well come on come on
oh he's trying to he's trying to bounce
in i hear our genji in the vicinity
he did
oh there's a lot of them coming in this
hallway well just get your roadhog up
there don't go down there roadhog
or may they walled it up this was a well
executed push yeah they kept that old
get on the point people who aren't
snipers
sometimes you gotta oh man they had all
their old [ __ ] hell they had all
their all lined up oh well done it's
[ __ ] well done yeah
you know sometimes you gotta give credit
where credit is due oh [ __ ] the four
olds popped at the end i think yeah that
was pretty vicious yeah oh he's got that
scarecrow junkrat skin that's a cool
that's yeah that's from world of
warcraft that's uh one of the harvesters
from duskwood or not duskwood from uh
ah i forget the name of the face
oh
your teammate says everyone runs from
heels
i don't know why
look at that they got dealt with
uh
i didn't even get to look in how well
birch man all right let's let's pop out
of here i'll log out
all right you want to hop in yeah i'd
like to play a little bit i'm going to
play some overwatch yeah i think we have
to log in totally to do this i'm going
to play some overwatch uh yeah to switch
out of the
the brackets uh all right uh let's do
the
can you just change user is that an
option logo there you go log out all
right there we go here i come to switch
to things
oh god i hate real life it's not
overwatch overwatch is so vibrant
and they come out of overwatch and it's
like
the reality of of reality it's just
colorless mauve i hate it hey what's up
chad how you doing
ah
this is what eurovision would be like if
it was a fight to the death says dom
mf and johnson that's a good point
that's a good point chris waters trying
to figure out has bought on that
password i remember it but i don't this
makes it look like i'm really small but
my seat is just lower
there we go
thank you so much to everyone who's
watching on uh
on twitch.tv forward slash gamespot of
course on the youtubes as well hit that
like and subscribe button make sure you
do we're streaming all day long here
folks
we are uh going to be playing for
another
two hours here about 30 minutes time
we're going to swap it out like my heart
is coming on
and uh yeah we're going to play some
more overwatch we're at the lobby of
course today as ever
2 p.m pacific that is two and a half
hours time no matter where you are in
the world chris is trying to figure out
his password is so good he entered this
last night on very fine on the other
situation you are logging into the
america's server very important my email
address i mean you can just jump in on
mine if you want he's only six skins
this one doesn't work he's on my six
skins if you missed it earlier we bought
forty dollars worth of uh skins on
the uh via the in-game store and open
them all up you want me to give it a go
sorry danny my
password situation is uh compromise hey
don't worry about it bro give me get me
those hot zenyatta stats
yes
that would be wonderful that would be
really good hey look it's chris waters
and danny roy he's top sides let's do a
little d
i'll just fit that one there and then
i'll just put this one here and then
we're all good i think look at that look
at that hot live producing
no chris doesn't have a name anymore
that's all right let's play the game
let's check it out i'm a ghost all right
we're going in here we got our we got
our friente rocking the
uh
icon that we acquired the most
duplicates of yes i believe that is the
horde
if i'm not wrong
i did play wow for a good half a decade
yeah it's been a while it was a long
time you played that that wow yeah that
was that world of workout games pretty
alright still got a bunch of snowballs
from 2005's winterfest or whatever
uh thank you so much for watching ray
gillian
appreciate it scoops you hanging out in
the chat i was playing with him last
night he did one he was doing all right
now what do you guys want for the first
dlc character support tank
uh defense or offense ask samba16
uh i don't know i don't really know i
didn't even have time to change my
sprays man that's famous sorry the first
first dlc
i'd like i don't know i'm kind of more
interested in maps to be honest i've
been playing playing these maps for half
a year it feels like all right because
it has been
uh gupta makes a point of maybe a
builder because there are kind of only
two there's like there's kind of only
one this person chose mercy let's see if
they switch come on in bastion switch
switch switch switch
get that hot level one pharah hmm
brilled killer world killer eric tay
doesn't know what to pick he's the
hottest uh
he's the highest level power character
we have here man look at that skin
do you want to moat
you see i want to know what america has
been up to what it sounded like that's
weird i mean donald trump's almost
present how about that
yes
all right i get that i can hold that
front of your hero details i want to
view heroes
folks are saying they'd like more
modes
one of the interesting things i learned
when i went to blizzard was that they
don't really think of the
the modes as anything other than the
maps
like because they're you they don't
duplicate modes over maps so like
they think of hanamura as hanamuras
like i'm sure it's like a whatever and
this is like a payload one but
but also it's just like the dorado map
you know
it's weird
also if you watch the latest soldier 76
video it suggests that the payloads are
full of pinatas which is amazing
i'm very into that all right chris
waters here on the point
he's got a reinhardt on and he's hitting
junkrat or yep sure is roadhog getting
dead
sorry i got my australians mixed up
widowmaker there forgets that she's able
to get in the air
what's up all you nerds oh
genji behind me yeah you got a discord
orb on your on your tail discord orb is
such a problem but i got three kills out
of that push forward and i'm gonna
respawn closer to the payload than all
of those people so i feel good about
that totally worth it if you can get a
positive kill death ratio on the early
early spot it really pisses the rest of
them off um
i think you're okay i think maybe he
spawned earlier
all right he can't orb me through behind
you
oh
yeah that genji's causing problems
especially because none of your team are
here
that's annoying hey widowmaker figured
out you can go upstairs
good work congratulations so sitting
down gen pop in fact the two buildings
there to the right are great places for
her to sit
the that started us on defense
all right let's come back around on my
team side
all right yeah
everyone got may altered but
oh no five really oh no
ah but i bounced her away
i already survived you got it i'm okay
you got a heater there anyway
yeah all right
i should have hammered down there gonna
use that the hot
use it yeah
uh i don't
i don't feel like a junk maze there
that's bad oh god not a good situation
oh frozen no
oh my god your health went into two what
is happening you're held it into two and
back up again that is so crazy the
health but the whole way down
nice work
a little bit more oh we got a zarya in
helping you matt
whoa you are jump yep
well his buddy's gonna blow you up
but hey i pushed him back i don't know
if anyone's behind me they are i'm in
trouble okay okay okay
can someone just go back there and kill
drunk all right yeah diva you should
probably be on that
yeah you're a big target for him to be
launching those things
can you hit f on him and be like yo
attack him i don't know is that like a
thing
ah that just said understood all right
you trying to get away that was pretty
good away from me you're doing a good
job here this is like
surprising wow i don't know how you guys
managed to do that yep i thought you
were getting totally murdered
just just anything about me may is the
worst she's so annoying she's so
annoying
oh dude
unlucky unlucky but i made her alt it
was worth it oh that's pretty funny the
gamble right i was gambling she was
going to come out early
push it good
so here's the thing right a lot of
people folks in the chat star play
finish asking about the esports angle on
this and like i get that there will be
high level play of this game but what
i'm way more excited about is the fact
that this is i feel like this is going
to be such an important like such a
played game by just regular people who
want to play in fps and don't care about
competitive life oh no like literally i
nice
may is my most loath character to face
as reinhardt well you got your you got
your hot
oh nice almost scooped up two of them
got your rolls as well
like i'm sure everyone's gonna jump on
this and trying to esports it's a
blizzard game
you just got dunked on hard by that guy
i tried to put my shield up uh
oh here we go oh beautiful though
what do you think about the esports
angle on all this this is how much i
hate you mate
mr waters uh i think it's i think it's
awesome that there is going to be high
level play but so you're
to your point danny like yeah it is
definitely a game that's gonna oh no
she's such a jerk it's the worst like
look i feel like may is like the hardest
counter to reinhardt yeah i'm just not
obviously not great at handling it i
didn't know zarya was coming down the
pipe uh but we got it to the we got it
to the point so we're moving along right
along here that the thing that does
excite me about this game though is that
universality is the fact that it feels
like something that hello friend
it feels like something that yeah you
can a lot of people are gonna be able to
play a lot of people are gonna get into
and i think you're seeing that already
with like how much art people are
creating about the game right uh
you know
how much excitement there was coming out
of the beta like people tweeted
i mean for a beta to show off every
single piece of like every map every
mode every character and for people to
still be excited about it
is like
pretty remarkable i'm just gonna go back
up here yeah yeah it was pretty much the
whole whoa hello
oh you got your boy here if you can get
that ult before he comes over that'll be
real handy
i don't even see him i think he's behind
us oh no he's just up there
yeah that's a great play of the great
area to do a junkrat alt is from above
basically anytime you're attacking from
an angle that the enemy is not looking
at is always a good move that's why i
like some hot widowmaker flanking what
are we doing here
good team situation
back on the down slope up here
all right folks hit that payload
let's just let's do the old
spin
go ahead sit and spin
yep
yeah maize over there don't worry
watch you get
zenyatta and widowmaker's efforts to do
nice
oh beautiful thing of beauty
and now i'm now i'm discorded and so
that's a bad situation
but you did the right thing you kept
kept it moving just gotta get all those
jerks off it now okay okay
nice
yeah i always forget that like the
you can totally just watch your back
yeah oh no that's a bad that's bad
he's on top of me with his sword and
everyone everyone wants to hit reinhardt
come on
justin calvary in the chat what's up sir
blizzard's own justin calvert in the
chat
sure yeah sure you guys are having a
great day in the studio
here we go may you stay away from me
second point done did i strongly dislike
you about three minutes to finish the
fight called in a bastion in here if
your pharah is like the death zone
can i charge into this yes how's your
all doing now oh my god i'm in such a
bad place
oh it's amazing
i just wanted to cancel this all real
bad that zenyatta is really quick with
the discord orb that's what you gotta do
as zenyatta when you're first engaging
anyone your first press on an enemy
should be the discord orb yeah you don't
even have to necessarily like
that god damn me
oh sorry i didn't get there fast enough
uh justin calvert in the chat saying
they're having a great day of blizzard
today
unsurprisingly
who's over here
must be fun first time they've launched
a new ip in 17 years
although it feels like this game's been
there for months but he's behind me i
don't know
ah
yeah that's another tricky thing about
junkrat uh
the bombs come at you from different
directions it can be tough to like zero
it right in on them
you keep spawning out of sync with
everyone as well which is a little bit
annoying yeah i was just about to say
just like get in there oh watch your
back
i mean one of the problems is your team
doesn't really have a pharah or
like any sort of decent
fast assault character it's a
oh who do you have
melted by that
what's what's the team look like at the
moment
um the breakdown
all
right
oh really
but i mean so yeah what do you do in
this situation danny like you recognize
your team has a lopsided situation yeah
in here i go from straight for pharah
because she's there's so much in
interior
like height level in here
and
they're going to basically be shoring up
defenses that you need somebody who's
able to like
dump high levels of damage
uh from uh oh no i wanted that to go
away
from you know from it from a decent
distance which you're never gonna have
with a lot of those tanks i mean diva is
a good shot in here because she's able
to like get around and flank
whereas like reinhardt's a real question
is who do i like in this situation right
you've seen a lot of pharaoh let's try
some soldier 76 i'm not oh yeah i got
that hot skin too
we're all soldiers now 90 seconds let's
see the future tanks can help us with
pushing stuff
justin says he heard rumor there might
be pizza for lunch at blizzard today
we won't soon see the likes of these
days again
cool good job soldier
got 11 seconds anyway i hit the bastion
but i did not uh
pull back and do my healing thing
properly
that's it
there's two of them on there see if i
can get there fast enough with my sprint
nope
a lot of a lot of skulls
hello
i'm here
worth a shot
you weren't a coward like me on the
voskaya industries one just throw myself
on it just sat back there nerds uh luna
asking when game spots review goes live
i think my heart is gonna have it
finished sometime later today i think
he's what he's waiting to see is like
you know there's been in some
some connectivity issues some server
stuff across the different the three
different platforms that it's on uh so
not too bad i don't think i haven't had
like problems that have been yeah real
bad at all he's just waiting to see if
that all settles that down or if it's
actually a real big problem nice damage
blocking i mean the last thing you want
to do is review a game only for the
servers not to work chris waters
reviewer of halo anniversary edition
which
the review didn't go live until like six
weeks after the game came out so we
realized how oh my god
all that online multiplayer situation
that's a perfect example of why we don't
do that because if you had reviewed that
game and given it a score based on the
server as being fine and potentially if
all these four games worth of
multiplayer matches work right
incredible and a lot of people did a lot
of other publications did and then you
know had to eat sour cake on it for a
little while what the hell is
i just make up metaphors sometimes
symmetra got chihuahua
cake i like it though but yeah uh
yeah i mean that's a and it is i mean it
is a tough situation you know in terms
of like
you want people want the review people
want to read it but at the same time you
want to do right by the review and like
what is the point of the review it's
to be informative to be accurate to be
something that people can trust to be
like okay yeah uh this this is worth
so there is a review in progress already
if you if you need those details we
obviously don't score it ahead of time
yeah um it's really weird at the moment
i i only noticed ign doing this recently
but they now score their reviews and
progress yes
and it has like it's written in like big
gray letters like almost like yo
metacritic don't take this one don't
take this
yeah it seems a bit strange
so here's your symmetra tactic
anytime you see it says e over somebody
press
anytime someone teleports look for them
and press e on they face oh yeah good
point because this uh
yeah this
the shields you know it's it's an extra
50. it doesn't it's not like a huge
difference maker but it can make a
difference oh you're going to ruin some
days with those turrets it's like some
cheeky turrets around you know my
favorite things about this game is is
all the ammunition all the weapons just
watch how they like
watch out how they like bob around as
you're walking
it's like so satisfying
just watching the like animations you're
like oh yeah because this thing is like
a little claw action
look at you spreading about all over the
place oh dude that's what i love to do
as symmetra is just start so you can do
how many six of those six at a time yeah
i'll put another one
up here you don't want to put up too
high and then what i do is just like you
know i have to wait for my i need to
survive until my ultimate is ready
because the teleport is like kind of the
whole point
of that how did that
uh
i think that was probably a genji back
over there okay but they don't seem to
be pushing things too much so is that
right not gonna come off the pipe
do they have that much range actually i
didn't realize not not attack not a not
a huge amount of range but
yeah this tracer is loving destroying
all my turrets i mean let her do it
right like go ahead if that's what you
want to do that's fire you're not
putting on my those two tracers oh no
there's a tracer and a genji
yep what's up nerds
what's up nerds yeah
i don't want to join that detective i'll
come into here
this is what this is this is where i'm
going to put my teleporter right
i am going to kind of try to line they
are very very actively destroying all of
my stuff all right it's rude and you're
like ten percent away from getting your
ult now as well yeah but this is going
to be a little too too it's going to be
too forward a position to put the alt
right because
the point is right there so i'm probably
going to put it maybe back here instead
um
and you got one percent left on it when
i put it down uh-oh it pushes don't let
him kill you
put that there and then i can like you
know oh yeah there we go
try to protect it a little bit
they're not going to do a ton of damage
but they're definitely going to help
the teleporter's been destroyed by
somebody and i got clobbered
not a great start forward symmetra this
team is doing pretty good work on us
yeah it looks like it we have no tank
to stop them yeah it seemed like they
got they're pushing way too hard on you
so i feel like i should switch to tank
but i want to give symmetra another life
and we'll see how that works out
probably not super good this is when i
should be adaptable i don't know what's
the what's the sort of hierarchy in
terms of when do you uh you know switch
your strategy when do you make that
change i'm not gonna step out there
because i'm pretty sure that is an enemy
alt
it's yeah usually at this stage it's
like okay let's have a look at the team
make make up and see where we're missing
yeah so this is where you've got another
uh diva
maybe or a rhino or a roadhog yeah
lucio's already hopped in there and
there's zenyatta you've got two healers
for some reason roadhog he's another
character i like to play and also i
think does pretty well on defense
uh just in terms of disrupting
big pushes and having survivability yes
and watch your left is somebody there i
think
yeah just being able to like drag people
in like that because they're already on
the front line just pulling them a
little bit further closer than they'd
like oh they dropped the beat too oh
they're firing in the hole oh god
it's all bad a lot of what's happening
there
yeah
so i probably i think i overextended a
little bit there i should have stayed in
the chokepoint a little bit i wanted to
push them back off that point but we
definitely should have just seeded that
point and not all died terribly probably
oh but i forgot i can i can spray my uh
horrible baby monster
what oh yes do it
yeah
look at all that look at that pig
so like around here is a good spot to
like
do that nonsense
and then you want to back off of this
dude yeah he's almost when you don't
want to pull towards you yeah
sometimes they like will back off
because like if you land those shots you
can do a lot of damage to the health but
i was using my medium range shot there
i was expecting to get out of his
hammer but i should have been using my
short range which is the right click
right yeah
well the right click is the the shorter
range one
uh does this go somewhere cool no pretty
pretty not cool place
now they are making
waves on you guys
oh you're really good at hitting that
one
don't pay for me
that's like super good that's what you
gotta do as road hog
oh [ __ ] i thought
no way he got it
that's nonsense
well it all's well that ends well
armor from tay bjorn
tavior
he's gonna be looking for you all day
get out of there
nice
worst possible time for that to happen
oh you got that ult as well if you want
it yep i'll use that it's probably not
the greatest because the shield totally
neutralized it i thought it had pushback
but the shield neutralizes the push back
as it would seem bad alt adios adios ray
in the chat ray gillian's heading out
thanks everyone for watching
on gamespot.com on twitch.tv for such
gamespot i'm on facebook
and on youtube hit that like and
subscribe button on facebook live we're
streaming overwatch all day long chris
waters here that's a bad situation one
man team roadhog in it
he was doing all spray there as you go
out just
oh look at that i did not hit him i
that's like i can hit the hook more
reliably than like sometimes i
like miss the last the next shot i don't
even understand or maybe i'm just
glancing blue
load blue i glance blowed 2.18 meters
stuffed it oh beautiful yeah just murder
your buddy
your australian buddy
oh no where's that get away from me
you can just tell when it's her
missed him see i missed it's so tight
but i have my alt like i don't
understand like why did i miss that my
midsize just bad aim
it's like they come in sometimes and
they're shorter than i expect right i
don't know
what is a potential reason two and a
month it's contested though this is
prime old time if you can get it off
do it pop it
oh he encountered the old
oh
nerf you're
it was like 0.12 meters from the end or
something yeah or was on it i guess you
can you start going backwards please
shoot that guy up top
oh unlucky
you gotta turn on top of the payload oh
you get that shield
oh i thought i had my thing why didn't
that hit genji
or whatever
nice work oh oh oh oh oh give me the
juice
beautiful
yeah i got on that time
no one spitting twice dead ah may come
on get in there what a mayblock
this is stressful come on come on baby
two minutes a lot of people did that
time so they should be all back on it
now you guys have done way better on
this last point than i was expecting
after seeing what the team did earlier
on that point 107.
oh he blocked that good
ah
zoom out good fight not a good fight
that's it
what time is it
oh it's uh you got one more indian uh
yeah
awesome
oh
shining grain
typical was on your team
so yeah yeah that was a solid reinhardt
i definitely did not evade him as much
as i needed to you need to stay
away from that friggin
that was really good well placed
solo yeah i'm gonna go for the teammate
boost
although 23 eliminations this guy was
this genji was really garlic
both of these
genji they had solid genji and i can't i
can't ever vote for the other team
unless they do something unless they do
something real good like there's some
jerk healer that just won them the game
sometimes i will vote for the other team
out of spite for my own team if we go
yeah it's real bad
not all the time and i'm not i'm not
proud of it you losers
[ __ ] yeah no no one was worthy of my
voting for those other guys
oh my goodness
all right king's row
who's someone else to who's in other
people you're attacking a request for
people they want to play oh i love an
attacker widowmaker or fire on this one
it's real good say that about every
single map you play i know it's the best
they work for everything that's all you
need to do i will actually play zenyatta
this time not take you let me play
zenyatta i love fat pandas watching from
brazil what's up buddy
thanks for hanging out with us today oh
it's got like just the glowing
molten law
look at that
it's got glowing orbs
let's give me a tank
sign a douche tank tank tank tank tank
tank i called that movie sign a douche
new york for like five years
until like because you were being a
douche because i didn't know it was a
place until like
my girlfriend told me like six months
ago
that it was synecdoche it doesn't even
look like that synecdoche
well it's also there's also a place in
new york called schenectady yeah that's
yeah so it's like a play on words or
whatever
it's like a funny play on words
i don't actually know i think it i think
that is a noun or a that's nectar he's
actually a word it's just mr kaufman
being a funny dude
look at my big orange bracelets
oh they're so cool
man i don't know i'll play enough of
this dude
it's so fun just like i like that like
these are like very direct right all
these animations those hands are so cool
really good but then this
whenever he throws an orb it's he like
slings it i bet whoever when they made
this character but it's so much fun and
his voice is so good too
his voice is just so
soothing
so how much damage does that discord orb
do like how badly does it debuff that
get edged
uh it's it's like maybe 50 percent
wow oh yeah it's pretty high god that
lucio dumped health oh oh oh
bad times to your left
says symmetra i think
with a uh
with her dumb oh it's one of those guys
too take care of it thanks dave
who wants that lucio
oh he's going in
oh there's a turtle
health one health one health
you have one health
there we go oh you got your you got your
olds
go away bastion
what a play
what a play chris waters yeah get some
cranberries
oh you should ban you they should ban
you i do like me
look at that you gotta kill that guy
from that distance jeez yeah zenyatta is
real gnarly at range gotcha dude how
many kills do you have uh four
eliminations
nice work
oh here's what you do with the bastion
you charge it up and then you edge
around oh that's gorgeous release it all
in one go but
he escapes
and by escapes i mean totes died
yeah you've got the discord or behind
you buddy
and the discord are also like keeps them
in your sights yep so you can do that
damn
this is exactly why you should play as
everyone because i did not realize he
was this uh
that he had all those effects as well
yeah they are hating you like they they
oh they're they just think you suck one
i want to get this guy i want to get i
can't get him don't have a line
i want to help you genji but i can't i'm
sorry
all right we're good we're cool
we're lighting people on fire we're
drawing attention towards a little
turret over there you can hear the grind
where is it
that honestly that lucio is just like
you're ruining his lunch like it's so
fun
every single time he comes up
this push is ridiculous this push is
absolutely ridiculous
you're gonna finish this with like okay
how did you stay alive with like a
hundred and fifty health or whatever he
has that whole time pretty sir i mean oh
my god hello teleporter
oh and you got your alt just sitting
there oh no oh no oh no your way
somebody give you a heel like i shot
that dude once and i got it wanna pop
that out yeah sure why not
let's just put myself at that
oh god it wasn't enough
i'll give it a little heal oh beautiful
absolute destruction you only had like
few him up only had like six minutes to
play a game and you guys did it just
pushed straight through like four
minutes probably oh yeah come on let's
get playing the game otg on that one no
i'm almost happy you didn't because it
would have said my name and that that's
not nobody nobody would have known play
the game that mr chris waters is well
this was part of that huge push that we
did that just like kept them off this
point yeah well you killed like four of
them there and also
did your alt and push forward so kept
them all alive
look at that four transcendence oh give
yourself a heal i'll give you i'll do it
for you oh i gotta do my maintain on
that obj
look at that disgusting amounts of
healing that was good sixteen hundred
yeah well that's only um
thanks dude but that's only the
transcendence healing done so right i
actually did more healing and i got
eight eliminations and two assists
two defensive assists like what is what
is the defensive assist when you're
attacking um if anyone's if uh
is i think coming in now yeah so let's
back on out here i can see that door
opening up
oh michael how you doing my friend come
in here
all right friendos i gotta go uh we're
tagging other folks in but thanks so
much for watching that was a blast glad
i went out on a high note with my boys
yeah nice work that was beautiful uh
this is actually starting again let's
get out of there because we need him to
log in from this game
uh you guys can open a little oh wait a
second i already wait wait one more one
more for the road
box one more for the road
our 50-second loot box of today's stream
see what's in there come on baby
oh dirty blues
we don't need no dirty blues
i already got this one give me some cash
money oh i'm back over a thousand
remember this all right see y'all in the
ring
see you later chris waters uh all right
i'm out of here too mahari who are you
playing with
oh sweet
mr jake the snake
let's uh let's back our asses out of
here yeah we opened we opened 50
two loot boxes i guess then in total it
was good fun
we got some cool stuff uh yeah that's is
it recording should be reporting yeah
no it shouldn't be yeah was it not
recording
did you hit stop yeah oh that's why
you're doing it okay cool yeah you got
it all right here you go there you go
cool all right you know how to use this
thing right all right
see you later dudes
the lobby on at two o'clock when's the
review going up uh tomorrow morning at
6am pst
yep
what's going on everyone
um
all right
what's up um so this is
our all day long overwatch stream uh
danny and chris just passed the baton to
mike and i um once he gets signed in
we'll get going
so you've been playing a lot of
overwatch
yeah i've been playing on all three
platforms since launch so unfortunately
i'm not like super far in on each one i
think i'm like level
eight on pc nine
uh but yeah beta early access i played
probably like 70 something hours total
um
okay so i'm level eight here just get
right in i'm gonna invite see who's on
tay and then and you're reviewing it you
don't like it that much do you it's all
right uh my review in progress is pretty
glowing my full review will be up
tomorrow morning
um
oh no tay's out now
he's not playing with us okay i got my
blank taste shirt on so
if anything goes wrong we can still put
the blame on him
uh so yeah so this stream i already said
is going all day we're gonna jake and i
the last segment until like 1 30 pst
before
we get into uh the lobby and whatnot and
talk a lot about overwatch i'm sure for
one of the segments um so yeah we're
gonna be streaming pretty much up until
the lobby probably around a half an hour
to 10 minutes before the lobby lobby
will start take a little break and then
after that there'll be more uh overwatch
yeah
get right into it all right attack i'll
just start with mccree
i just bought a new mccree skin
on ps4 or something
i have enough for a decent skin right
now so mccree is voiced by troy baker
right
i think this is what i've heard probably
i don't know it
sounds like sounds like him
uh mike mccree
mike how's your love can you talk just
for a sec yeah say your level is low
does that sound better
uh can that sound good everybody hear me
what do you think chat
well
wait to get back i turned it up a little
hopefully we're good
get the tumbleweed
so what's the deal with mccree
he's kind of dirty with his flashback i
like him a lot um
he's one of those players that like you
definitely have to oh that's a sick skin
that is pretty sick i mean in a military
shooter kind of way um
he's not that didn't mean that as an
insult anyway i've never seen i haven't
seen that skin up close
he's actually
so obviously mccree he's he's moved
slowly as you can see right here but
he's got the fan the hammer
he just unloads all six bullets but it's
a little hard to control he's got the
pretty precise just one shot primary
flashbang which
is a really good counter for like tracer
reaper
characters like that i feel like i do a
lot better with mccree on pc just
because of the precision definitely of
course you were kicking when we played
at the beta you were doing really well
with him on ps4 yeah he's
he is
he's kind of like hanzo actually i
really like hanzo too um
obviously in the sense that
nice
but they're not like yeah getting that
so much concentration the peacemaker
yeah
it does not have much obviously you do
that okay i might just get in there this
probably isn't ideal but i want to do
something
who's with me someone else around here
yeah it looks like you're all by
yourself
oh [ __ ] 76 not someone i want to there
we go
can you like disengage that hook early
like [ __ ] god could he have just
disengaged that hook and he would have
fallen in the pit um
i believe once you reach out you might
be able to cancel it with another
ability
because i've used roadhog before but i
usually just launch it and pull them in
yeah and then just shut down he rode
playing against roadhog he's my
i know a lot of people hate junkrat
don't like bastion but roadhog is the
one i i mean i love playing junkrat and
bastion but roadhog's the one i just
cannot stand playing
because most characters my favorite
characters are all pretty fragile like
hellflies
oh yeah zarya zarya is my favorite
character hands down of course i feel
like i don't see you play zarya that
much but i haven't played with you that
much damn it um i like mccree um
so yes make with make with the funny
this is on pc uh they want to know what
mouse sensitivity you're playing at i'm
guessing you don't uh this is a little
more sensitive than i have said on my pc
it feels like okay i'd have to pause it
and check
so dead eye is also is a tough ultimate
to
use
really it's not so it's it's good but
you have to know how to use it you have
to like start behind cover and then come
out
the i love it when like you hear a meal
high noon and then he dies yeah
not when i'm playing him i don't like it
in that case but
oh there it is
so that's the flashbang okay so if i do
my dodge roll it'll automatically reload
there's no animation i just have six
bullets in my clip so he's got this cool
loop that you can do
so you shoot roll
and now it's reloaded that's pretty good
the hammer i just have to wait from the
but as you can see the flash bang fan
hammer is like a pretty
mo some tanks it'll kill with six
bullets but uh again it's kind of
hard to control a little bit
oh god damn it
yeah he was waiting for you yep
all right get him a cree duel uh it's
really funny there's been twice when i
played the game that uh
another mccree and i have done dead eye
together
and we kind of walk out and duel who
came out on top i
won both of them actually
oh all right one was funnier though
because it was just me and him like in
this weird
side hallway without anybody else around
so what kind of player do you think
would prefer mccree
like uh
like one-on-one kind of player um like
if you like genji you'll probably like
mccree
it seems like a little more precise oh
man i thought that was my reinhardt
still he seems like a more precise um
soldier 76 but maybe not as precise as
genji solar 76 is very much like a
medium range i would i would even say
like mccree is
more similar to genji because he is
really mobile with his uh his dodge roll
yeah i might switch over who we have
here i'm not gonna stick with mccree i
love the security chief
so other than mccree and zarya what are
some of your favorites so far junk rat i
really like lucio
um
i really like um
playing reinhardt he's pretty simple but
it's
i'd be busy i feel more like a team
member when i'm playing his rhino yeah
um
i actually really like uh start playing
zenyatta a lot more last night i've you
know i played everybody but zenyatta was
always one of those ones who's chris was
just talking about him playing
apparently played him really well i
didn't see the match just now but you
know he's one of those under under value
characters
chris is also pretty good at this game
so
you fall i don't know
yeah i think he fell be a little more
frantic if that reaper wasn't with me
all right um
um yeah it looks like somebody already
answered it but the review will be up
tomorrow morning so we don't have a
exact score quite yet
well maybe we do but you won't know
until tomorrow
oh come on yeah i had 10 health today i
was waiting for him to kill me
took him a while though
yeah
he's a soldier 76 with a scrub yeah
well i was too
i like going up there though
i don't really use soldier 76 he's
really good though i mean if he's an
attacker for sure yeah i've used him a
couple times and every time i've done
really well with him i just don't have
that much fun with him
oh nice
yeah he is
oh man the stairs there he's a pretty uh
vanilla character
but i mean if you want to just go like a
simple kind of
medium range get a lot of kills and
you're good
yeah good place to start too yeah
i might switch over to who do we need
do you have support
um yeah we got mercy
oh man the hornet's nest
dang
the flashbang killed him
let's see if you can get a get a good
alt yeah go for the dead eye trying to
get around
i try not to
skirmish
nice
that's pretty cool i love the animations
with him pulling it back
yeah
hey i got deadeye now
oh what i feel like i don't know how
that didn't kill
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm not gonna use it now so this
would probably be a bad time to use it
because i don't have anybody in my
sights right now i don't
have any cover you're really vulnerable
when you use it but yeah
there's yeah there's going to be some
people coming around there i'm sure
got two of them
behind the last second yeah i mean it's
better than nothing i could completely
[ __ ] it up
oh he got my flashbang i didn't know he
could do that he got it i think so i
think he deflected it thanks didn't work
see i definitely threw it
i have no idea oh he didn't kill me
damn we just got
defeated
i hate junkrat i don't like you
oh man i'm gonna show him kill me
maybe not
i like genji a lot too
genji's pretty cool he's tough to use
most of the offensive characters
maybe not most but a lot of the
offensive characters are
tough to use
yeah like a lot of them are skill-based
well no that's not true because you have
like widowmaker hanzo or defensive
who are you going to vote for i don't
know i don't like the other team i
wasn't really that impressed by my
teammate
i wasn't impressed by me so
fair enough all right
all right
i play some hanzo
now
give uh your favorite characters
um
i'm not sure i really like widowmaker
god i'm not i'm not backing down zombie
hickey
yeah someone else pick hanzo yeah
um
you like defensive characters you said i
like widowmaker um i like pharah a lot
i've only played one game with farah
though but i did really well so
this morning this morning yeah yeah i've
been playing on ps4
uh i played that on xbox one oh yeah
i might have i mean obviously for review
i'm playing on all three platforms but i
might just keep doing that to
it's random loot so on like xbox i have
some skins i like and whatnot ps4 same
thing
so how does one of those characters i'm
either on with or i'm severely off um
let's hope the former yesterday was
doing pretty well that's what i noticed
with hanzo like
that timing is not something like i
don't know the timing with the bow like
sometimes i'll have it other days i
won't yeah
i like his movement speed his mobility
too which yeah
his uh
it's pretty oh yeah it's awesome
tay and i were talking about how
it takes it a little bit the dragons
only form
close to impact so if i wanted or they
start close to impact i don't know if
that makes sense so say they're there
instead of shooting it there
to hit them it would be better to go
here because the dragons will start here
and continue oh yeah it'll just go right
a little nuance that yeah
but his his recon arrow is super uh
underrated is a split arrow if you're
good you can kill like entire teams with
it that might be an exaggeration but
forgive me
so what's what's the best strategy with
hanzo then he's defensive characters so
yeah kind of kind of back a little bit
try to pick him off from afar do you
like hanzo more than widowmaker yeah
widowmaker i'm not
great with
i also like that he has these like
separate arrows that are like
that like
i like he's a little more adaptable i
feel like a widowmaker although
widowmaker has that like you know a
sorrowful kind of thing
so they know i'm here
whoa
so that's super helpful like if like
you're on a team with hanzo he's not
using his recon arrows it kind of pisses
me off
yeah you got to take down pharah
i got him
nice
oh that should have hit nice
thanks
oh i see what you mean
i got one his his if you're getting
consistent damage his recharge is pretty
fast like in this situation i've
actually got good sight lines i don't
have to aim too much for like how much
they're bunching up which is when i like
it's so fun to be hanzo when they're
just clumping up you just start
launching uh infinite like arrows not
infinite but just keep watching yeah
repeatedly
brother against brother right here
oh yeah genji's brother right
yep yeah hanzo's the older brother beat
the [ __ ] out again you made him like he
had to be a cyborg to survive and then
he met zenyatta and zenyatta like taught
him to come become like to be at peace
with the
why did they fight
um was it wanted to assume more
responsibility in their crime family in
japan and then now hanzo kind of
renounced it after he realized he just
killed almost killed his little brother
oh okay oh if you play hanamura you you
can see the arrows from the short
video that they made
in the walls and stuff
it's pretty cool like they look they
look like hanzo's arrows with a little
blue cybernetic tips
oh watch out
dang it that was uh widowmaker i don't
like the domain
though yeah
usually wins that one
so when you're playing hanzo what are
like your responsibilities
um
like the recon arrow is really helpful
um
if you're good yeah farah like uh
tanks are really you're good against
tanks because with a full charge shot
you're pretty yeah you do quite a bit of
damaging and stay far away
oh thank you
um yeah and then
same with uh you're actually pretty
mobile like um
damn uh you can like close range you
could feather a little more like
that's like the equivalent of the
assault rifle with widowmaker kind of
um
yeah you're good for like um
bastion turret kills you're kind of like
a assassin i'd say like specific targets
when you want to call them out you're
good against but you're also good at
holding chokepoints like i said because
you're you're all is really good against
like narrow yeah
oh got a lucio
nice
someone get that widowmaker how did i
not hit her
i don't think so yeah there she is
she's like a small target too yeah
damn it
oh he altered that's a weird oh yeah and
he's good against snipers oh we just got
revived
oh
he was waiting for me the entire time
oh i hate that dude when the uh the kill
cam shows like the object man the
killcam shows the objective uh
much farther behind what it really is so
then when you you're like oh we're fine
but then you actually
go to spawn and it's much farther oh
yeah i know what you mean
it might be what just happened
oh is this you
yep oh yeah but then i get revived and
die again from genji
dang we just had nothing to stop that no
yeah
looks like naked dragon did a good job
phillius32 says i never really like
these type of games but i am sort of
tempted
and it looks fun and complex
what would you say do you think if
you're not into first-person shooters do
you think this is a game that would
still kind of maybe not first-person
shooters but competitive sort of
shooters would you say this is a game
that you could yeah because it's fun
just to like play a character and learn
them there's almost like an rpg-ish kind
of
way like an rpg is kind of like you know
learning characters like uh
certain characters are kind of uh like
melee combat games some characters cater
well to shooter fans but others like
i don't need like mercy you don't really
have to be a shooter fan reinhardt you
don't have to be a shooter fan
kind of caters to a lot of different
play styles which is what makes it great
who are you going to be
what do we need i might go got someone
that i haven't been yet go tracer
oh that's the sweet skin yeah
got the aviators
she's got a cool backstory too so
originally when she
like the experiment went wrong i believe
and she
um
well tracer's actually a good character
if you don't like shooters too because
you're not really
you can kill people it's not your really
job you just have to annoy people yeah
just like a fly you're really good
against big tanks because they can't
it's tougher for them to just like
especially reinhardt you can dodge
behind shield turn around [ __ ] him up oh
man i hate going up against tracer's
reinert um
yeah there are enough things here if
you're not a shooter fan that i still
recommend the game because
even without the competitor even
considering the fact that it's
competitive it's still
there's a way you can contribute without
feeling like oh i didn't get enough
kills for my team or i didn't defend
that point well enough for my team
there's things you could be doing
have you played it much on xbox one a
little bit um not a ton
yeah the servers are just as stable as
they are on the other platforms
um yeah everyone's asking about it on
xbox one and i played a match this
morning and it was kind of fun i think
took
it was a little slow to find a match but
once i got in i didn't have any issues
uh someone else in the chat is saying
that he says and not a lot of people
tend to play the objectives in this game
have you noticed that so the people that
are good at the game will play the
objectives but yeah there are a lot of
people who play it like a team death
match and there's no team death match in
this game but people are kind of
conditioned so i think it'll take a
while before
people who are newer to this kind of
game will start actually realizing that
you can't just be you know
yeah i i imagine that's something that
like wants a lot of the more casual i
don't wanna say casual but once like
people who don't get as into it kind of
get weeded out the more hardcore fans
will
populate the servers and that hopefully
wouldn't be a problem for sure
but people also be better
because this is this is time for me
because i can kick my hands but
who is it
oh man
so yeah i feel like
so the matchups like that are kind of
like two skirmishers off by themselves
are pretty fun although i didn't win but
i feel like i don't play tracer much
it'll be tough to win tracer against
that
you have to really be using her mobility
against him but he's got some mobility
too if he lets her if he recharges fast
enough
that's why zarya is not really doing
much i need to figure out where all the
health packs are on these maps oh
there's [ __ ]
got her sticky bomb
oh i don't know why i just drew his
attention here
yeah run
nice
oh is that a widowmaker
she's actually good at taking objectives
because she's hard to hit when she's in
there
people
her once i capture this i should her ult
is pretty good for annoying holding
objectives too right or it's good yeah
well it's good for against groups
it doesn't have the biggest aoe so i
should really get off and start
dude i hate may with all my heart
she's really good taste hold his eyes
i've noticed
so i tend to not use the reverse time
thing unless i it's like my get agile
free card the boosts are what i accounts
for oh [ __ ]
that was our genji i hate when i was too
close to even see the glow the color is
that our sniper it's gotta be our sniper
oh man
oh there you go
got the health too that's the best thing
sometimes
i've tried before and it's mainly an
accident but you can actually time it so
you end up to like pick up the health
and then reverse it and pick it up again
if you get hurt um i wish i could do
that
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that
oh
nice
is that was that that may again
yep this is that genji again too
i get away from here it's your team
see if they can help me yeah there you
go oh coming out of there
that didn't oh anybody damn it that
sticky bomb didn't get anybody
didn't even dead we made a good push
though
so that's ideally where you want to be
the tracer was right up among them and
or at least like up near where they're
coming out of and just pestering them
and skirmishing
oops wrong turn
oh is that all should i i'm gonna wait
actually no probably shouldn't wait if
i'm tracer
oh man
that's a boost there
dude i'm on here
oh [ __ ]
nice
damn it
some more people are there for that all
tracer is tough
at least to play really what i found
yeah um
yeah like i think a lot of people just
focus on killing that's not i just kind
of
she's really fun because i
you can get in there
just annoy people get out and then just
keep
you know repeating all that yeah
all
right someone in the chat asks what this
game does better than uh battleborn and
i think you're one of the people who are
trying to like tell people that they're
not exactly like worth comparing
necessarily
oh this guy's gonna hate me
right um well they they they both
they're hero shooters right they both i
think overwatch does a better job of
combining a lot of different aspects in
that like you have the titanfall
character you have the
titanfall character you have a
counter-strike character you have the
call of duty character the
ah damn it um yeah you have the call of
duty character you have the like uh you
even have a quake kind of fair is kind
of like an old unreal tournament
quakeish kind of character it does a
better job of combining a lot of these
different ideas i know scott butterworth
and his battleborn when he was talking
about battleborn which he reviewed it
was saying that has a lot of ideas as
well but they don't mesh really well
overwatch they mesh really well
there are some
smaller balancing issues with certain
characters that but they don't affect
the overall game there is there are ways
to counter them and whatnot
get out of my face mae
um
that is pretty cool but it's more it's a
more refined experience battle born
battleborn is kind of like this grab bag
of different things
yeah
it's cool how may can just kind of like
block off that entrance and like yeah
it's just kind of like cut off just like
reform the map almost because zarya kind
of has like her graviton started just
kind of like makes choke points
i hate that noise
do you know how many maps there are 12 i
believe uh three per game mode because
there's three game modes but there's a
fourth it's like a hybrid between
payload and attack defend
and that's my favorite game mode nice
that move is so annoying
yeah i think even though there aren't
like a ton of maps in this uh
there
there is enough that you will ne i don't
think you'll ever get forward
there's one map i don't really like
there's a one map i really like
all right there's a few maps i really
like oh come on but i think like you
even like traversing you traverse and
play through maps differently based on
the character oh yeah i feel like it's
almost like yeah it's still the same
look and still the same layout but i
think like
i don't know you you play maps
differently depending on the character
you are and i think that kind of adds a
bit to the replayability right and
you'll you'll start to know characters
and maps and you're like oh i'm really
good with this character on this map and
what not
we have a genji too i can't tell which
one is which
uh we had one at one point we still do
first win for us
what two one of three
one of four i don't know this is the
third one one of three
yeah tracer's fun
just in case you're stopping by now this
is gamespot's overwatch stream we're
gonna be playing overwatch all day uh
except for a small break we're gonna
take in order to do the lobby so make
sure to stick around for the lobby if
you're watching us on youtube make sure
to like and subscribe
and yeah if you have any questions leave
them in the leave in the twitch chat and
we'll try to get to them yeah we're
going to 1 30 pacific um jake and i and
then get in the lobby and talk about
talking about a bunch of things but
i'm sure
some phaha yeah
but of course overwatch as well and yeah
our review will be up full scored review
there's a pretty a review in progress a
little more um detailed than those
things usually are because
the we've we already put like seven
hours in the game that's just to make
sure that servers are stable and whatnot
uh we'll have the full scored review up
tomorrow
6 a.m pacific unless
something drastically changes that but
right now that's that's the plan
i missed all of the stats like who did
what well did you did you make it on
anything i didn't make it on the voting
um no so we're attacking i'll go
i'll go reaper i'm not the best reaper
he's a good reaper and i'll go zarya
all right no one else in the office
plays zarya consistently i don't think
and she's your favorite she so what's
her deal she is interesting because
she's kind of this cool blend of classes
right she's a tank uh in the fact that
she you know project
uh does the projected barriers on
herself and other people and the tesla
cannon gets more powerful the more
damage you absorb with those shields
uh the tesla cannons good close range
with a steady laser or like a grenade
launcher far away
um and then her alt
so between shielding them like that and
shielding myself she's a tank and
whatnot like a buff for the other
characters but her alt is the graviton
surge kind of a mini black hole that
sucks everyone into it they can still
attack but it's really good for like if
you're with a hanzo you could say i'm
doing graviton surge suck it in he'll
shoot the arrow through all of them
use his uh dragon
uh
pharaoh is pretty good with her pairing
up with her
she's she buffs people she's not the
best for just like outright damage she's
got the grenade launcher which
it's got a really slow arc and pretty
decent damage for grenade launcher it's
not it's tough to hit though
yeah you get used to the arc it's a much
steadier arc than uh junkrat's just like
lobbing grenades
is um competitive
servers are those up no that'll be
later in june i think they said
okay someone was asking so yeah it
sounds like i believe it's they're not
up but um i believe it's a little bit
later in the next month
so you're gonna have to hold out a
little bit longer for competitive oh
they got a zarya too
i always take it personally when someone
else is playing the character i'm
playing and like if they're doing better
than me so i should just get out there
send them like hate messages and stuff
like that yeah yeah it's the only like
legitimate thing to do when you're mad
all right get up here buddy
where is my team i got a mccree
oh
zvz
yeah that looks tough to hit with
nice mccree
damn it she got out of there that was
crazy
i don't know there we go
all right so i should be up on the
payload hopefully it comes around the
corner because i should not be out for
myself really
she's one you to i like her because she
forces me on my comfort zone i'm not
normally a tank player but she you want
to be in the action absorbing damage
shielding everybody that's in trouble
healers are really good to shield you
know like merc or people that are pretty
vulnerable like mccree is a really good
person to shield yeah um and then
obviously the more damage they take the
more
shielding tanks they don't need the
shield as much but they're going to draw
fire and then you get more damage to
your laser she's got a lot of things to
think about she's like kind of a little
more nuanced than you might think as
most these characters are
what am i stuck on is that a bear trap
yeah
who drops those that's uh junkrat
another one of mike
a lot of people think he's kind of the
new character or another just because he
can spam the grenades
but no he's he's a he's a pretty easy
character
but if you're playing sorry well you
want to be shielding people almost like
as often as possible
oh yeah those grenades are hard to [ __ ]
see this is not a good matchup
do you have a sniper with you guys uh
with mccree is probably the closest
she knows it too she's not really
backing down
oh damn
someone's got to take her out i can't do
um dang yeah not going to stop that we
made a pretty good push we almost got
the checkpoint three minutes left
yeah she's one of those characters i
play because she pulls me out of my
comfort zone i don't like being right in
the middle of stuff and with her you
kind of want to be
not recklessly but
not like reinhardt but she you feel
vulnerable as her too but it's weird
like i said she's a weird character i
like her a lot
but it's kind of one thing i've noticed
with this is that i
tend to enjoy characters that i normally
wouldn't in most games yeah like
um i mean like with you zarya but like i
usually don't like playing medics or
healers or support but i was actually
having a lot of fun with mercy during
the beta
um and like normally i don't like rocket
launcher characters and stuff like that
i'd rather just have a machine gun but
fair i was doing pretty well with i
enjoyed that
damn thing i'm trying to clear them up
before we get back to the payload oh
they've been pushing it back i gotta go
up there
all right so yeah normally i'm not
playing that well i should be right up
on the payload but i didn't want them to
cause further trouble but yeah
um
one character i really want to get
better with is uh genji because i like
playing it a lot
genji's fun
you can really scroll screw people over
this sword too his like deflection thing
yeah that one that's like the best one
that you can deflect arrows back to
hanzo and whatnot
all right come on we really gotta get up
there
push it back pretty consistently
where's your team i don't know
they're pushing us back pretty well it's
something i guess hopefully that yeah
just kind of
didn't stop roadhog nope
i don't know where they are
so on your health bar it's divided like
it's white and blue what does the blue
mean
the white is just like armor
or sorry blue
one or the other either one all right
let's
oh they pushed it back a lot
so that's my all normally i would have
used it like when hanzo was ready to
shoot into them
but i don't know where my team is right
now so
yeah i feel like it's just been you
fighting these people
well yeah we're all rushing in one by
one right now it's not something i could
do to myself
all right let's move up
we have now we have to stay on the
checkpoint
no
dang it
someone's still on it i think the
soldier survived that
you got less people i thought
all right we got one person out yes
thank god for this lucio
junkrat's old can be deadly
yep
well you got teammates now
oh man he just dropped the beat
so what just knocked you away like that
uh
it might have been lucio pushing me
which was smart because all they need to
do is get us off the objective
of the game
zombie hickey he's doing playing hot
yeah she had like no opposition
there was like nothing really
i could counter her i feel like
because i'm not super impressed with
this play of the game neither there
wasn't that eventual game
epic thank you thank you
so which character you think of next
i don't know
uh i might go
i'd do some genji
depending on what the situation is i
don't know genji can be good on defense
too
if you're good with genji
it's good against those snipers too i've
noticed yeah
he's a really versatile character but
he's
he takes skill
i'm like a torbjorn
you're pretty good with torbjorn i
remember yeah he's
people who are decent with him will just
use the turret and kind of support it
but if you're good you can kind of learn
to use
his rivet gun and the turret as kind of
these two points of intersecting fire as
chris waters would put it um
it's the river guns kind of
underestimated a lot of times and then
with all
like i said you become these like two
characters almost
like oh junkrat soonish but playing
right now yeah junkrat would be a fun
one to show off
tanks
he's got that arc on this like after a
while arcs but he's pretty powerful
actually
i love his animation i know i was just
thinking that little drop shots
potential
turret placement's huge though i mean
not exposing the back of it and also
like putting somewhere you can kind of
defend it um initially early on i kind
of like to
just support my turret
down the road i kind of
becomes more of a
how can i flank him with my turret and
myself
notice he got hammer which is like last
resort melee but you need it for
upgrading
how do you you just pull out your hammer
and bash your turret upgrade yeah five
times a level two right level when it's
more of a just an annoyance
can you not place turrets right now yeah
are you just waiting to figure out you
can only do one at a time okay
can you upgrade it any more than that
uh the alt brings it to level three
okay
do you have to be near it or just
uh no you anywhere on the map that's why
it's pretty great
and it gets like rockets at level three
and then you yourself are your rival gun
as bob
oh come on kill him
do it
oh [ __ ]
and also i mean when you kill when dead
bodies drop you drop um
scrap you pick that up and you throw
armor down with it
that was pretty cool
so he's got a lot of uses then he's a
very very
he is a supporting character almost like
nice
all right so he seems kind of underused
i feel like i don't see people using
that often
so this isn't the best spot i think i'm
getting up here actually get away with
this we have another character up here
no i don't think we have enough time
yeah oh man
um
that was kind of unnecessary but i'll
take it
all right
i don't know why mercy chose just
revived me
he's like all right
um
do you know how he fits into the lore of
this game
he made like
really great weapons for overwatch and
then when he found out that overwatch
was kind of corrupt from the inside he's
like went off i think he went off by
himself in sweden uh
swedish yes sweden
uh but he was like the the engine the
weapons maker of the group
okay
[ __ ] so yeah i should be placing my
turret right now but
there are kind of characters that are
kind of like
sort of
villains
uh yeah definitely um as opposed to good
like but then one like it doesn't make
sense that tracer would be fighting on
winston and whatnot yeah because i was
watching the videos and tracer and
winston kind of seemed more like
they are yeah they're like best friends
yeah
then the nice people and then widowmaker
is more of a evil character and same
with reaver or reaper of course because
damn he's got a trench coat and shotguns
and he looks like death
um widowmaker was taken she was like the
wife of a wow we bunched up a lot that
was just
she was the wife of a french diplomat i
believe and then they needed to kill him
or
french something and then people took
her brainwasher and then she waited a
week and then killed him so she's like
brainwashed doesn't have who is this
widowmaker okay
that like video with widowmaker and
tracer fighting was pretty badass yeah
oh fair is gonna cause some issues
i just want to get this down
god
that's the most annoying thing
getter 404 says tor's backstories pretty
much i told you so in response to ai
uprisings
torbjorns torbjorn yeah oh yeah
this team we're playing is pretty good
yeah they seem to be doing they've been
working pretty well together
you took that one game off of them
though
i mean i haven't had a chance get my
turret down i just need to like
as extraction right now
level one it's not gonna do much
they just destroy it
armor take armor did not last long no
it's still there
damn
they are really moving up on us i'm
gonna switch all
in a second i just need these
use some minutes
with every death comes honor
with honor
redemption
that old is so dumb
oh man
they're walking on us
yeah i think they won
yeah i think they're gonna win
oh i got five people oh yeah
i'm gonna leave this yeah maybe try to
find uh let's find a different party
different group
maybe one will have a better shot
gingerbeard
fashion's backstory is kind of funny he
he's an omnic
so like people are naturally kind of
afraid of him but he went off
into like the wilderness like
thorough and
wanted to get closer to nature that's
why his overgrown epic skin is the one
that's like
it was with a pre-order whatever
overgrown epic was it just it's like
covered in he's covered in moss and
grass that's pretty cool that's why he's
got the bird and stuff like that in
there yeah
these matches i'm not even getting
enough time to get good medals
career best for damage done
let's leave this game
or not
um someone asked if there's leveling on
characters no there's not
you just unlocked there's 54 unlocks for
each character and you unlock them
randomly
yeah so there's like stats for
individual characters and whatnot okay
let's try torbjorn again i want to get a
good match in with him
he's got a sick beard yeah he does you
working on a beard like that kind of
yeah got a little bit going on it's
tattoos i'm gonna get that you get that
tattooed yeah
the beard tattooed are you going to get
those gears no those gears and his face
next to it
is his his hand is with the wrench yeah
or whatever that is looks like a wrench
or something
no sniper
there we go
sweet
all right looks like a pretty
well-rounded team
it's so nice to have a lucio
like it's one of those i feel like a lot
of people especially for neutral control
when both are rushing for the center
area it's like one you just don't think
about it you don't think about how
helpful it can be it's like no yes get
there eventually but
can help a lot so i don't want to get
shot right away i don't want them to
know it's here either i'm gonna put it
right here
another good spot is actually up here
because then you get this stairs and
down there but i'm gonna wait see how
that first one does
experiment a little bit
looks like these guys got this area
covered oh you already shot the arrow so
they're coming through here yeah
so how did you know that they were
hanzo's uh recon arrow forget the action
oh i didn't know that was a recon arrow
that's pretty cool so you fire it and
yeah like it's actually someone in the
chat made a good point it's a really
good before he uses alt because
you can see exactly where it's gonna go
because it goes through walls and
whatnot okay
and is it just kind of like
there's a radius from where the arrow
lands yeah it's a sphere
it's kind of cool widowmaker down there
torbjorn you actually kind of want to
stay mobile though right cause you pick
up the scrap and you get the armor
although that might not be the best
place for me to go
who was that was that junkrat yep damn
it i thought he was close to me
got a turret kill too my turret's in a
good spot right now sorry it doesn't
just destroy either when you die
dang i took you out all by himself still
at 25.
i wish that lucio is back here i know
scorpion's not the slowest character
though
actually i might prepare that i kind of
like that position
up there is pretty great
but they push yeah no yeah
oh you got him
armor
goddang
i thought it was a bear trap and then
i'll shoot at mccree
i love how low his field of view is
now you just look at uh like reinhardt
or something like that you just feel so
minuscule yeah
you're like pharah just flying above
everyone yeah
let's get by this year
actually another
one actually yeah do you think that's
going to do much from there it's pretty
from not where it was that's just like
you want to get the level one down as a
distraction [ __ ] at the very least
dude
people had my
what my turret just somehow killed him
oh i must it must it probably wasn't the
kill i just got the elimination get
someone else for them
nice can you heal your turret too yeah
you just hit it with a hammer more it
helps right there that makes sense
or the health's on the bottom of the
screen right there that's how i fix
things with bash it with a hammer
get some armor out get some armor
nope not doing that mccree right now
might be a good time coming up to use my
all if
they're in here far enough we're
actually kind of making a stand right
here
yeah i think you guys might be able to
hold out
oh maybe not [ __ ] that get back up
now he's gonna get him behind my turret
i think that's what he's going for
someone pointed out that his he's mostly
head like his character model is just
like just beard and yeah just a head so
there's like a huge like critical hit
box yeah
never thought of that
it's also short though
may not seem coming up
[ __ ] [ __ ] looks like he went the wrong
way though
oh he's coming for you
dang
help all right
nice
on my turret my level one turret
oh they're gonna make it they're gonna
make it to the checkpoint
no one else is
i'm my best dog
distraction right there i might be able
to upgrade that oh [ __ ] nope oh
that guy's gunning for you man
that reaper yep
he's doing his job he's locking off the
sides where i can't build a turret like
him and tracer if there's a torbjorn
they're pretty good counters to him
there's work to be done
should be getting more armor out too
dang they're pushing pretty fast
i mean at least this game has been a
little
a little more exciting than the last
couple
take it take it take it take it take it
oh this is not a bad spot actually well
they can come in behind me but
hurry up hurry up hurry up hurry up
oh behind you
[ __ ] reaper
yeah this guy's messing your game up
oh you're just all um
where'd he go
i don't know i think they weren't on the
payload that much
you're right minute left minute
i might be able to pull this off
oh there's diva there's [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh someone got here though nice
oh my turret did nice but my turret's
gone
it's okay did its job
take it take it take it
i feel like people don't realize that
that's armor on the ground
yeah who knows
32 asks if you see this being like an
esport sort of game i know danny and
chris talked better but
i think so yeah blizzard needs you know
like blizzard is not traditionally the
best with balancing so they'll have a
lot of work to do in the long run i'm
sure
but yeah i can see that happening for
sure um
it's got that much nuance like it's got
the team fortress kind of
layered
[ __ ] you dude
and then of course you killed junkrat at
close range
drops a suicide tay says blizzard will
definitely try yeah
but it'll be up to the community that's
what everybody says that's what epic
saying about paragon
not that i disagree but
that's like the thing
well as of now it seems like the
community's enjoying it
yeah uh anybody who i think the main
turnoff for people is that it's just
competitive
um which i'm not super i used to be like
big counter strike player i used to be
you know just into competitive games but
i'm not
widowmaker where she
yeah it's not
you know it's i'm not traditional i'm
not that competitive a player but i'm
enjoying this a lot
i'd like
especially recently a lot of games have
come out like titanfall and battlefront
uh
both have just multiplayer and they
don't really have a single player and i
was really turned off by the spot good
spot oh let's do it
oh we're gonna get it
yeah
yeah that's right
that was not a bad little
got a minute you got to hold out for
whole [ __ ] it's at full health still i
thought they would have
nice
she's on them
nice
get her away enter it
nice
that all actually worked out well
because i got the kill so that's what
you want to do ideally is get like a
kill with a rivet gun and the turret not
ideally but it helps when you can
get both of those
all right i got a rhino coming up so i'm
gonna
that turret's not in a bad spot i just
need to distract him from it 15 seconds
looks like we're pushing it back too
oh there he goes there's a reinhardt
down that was big that was big oh time
for that sweet revenge
damn nice that turret's doing its job
no one's touching either it's a good
spot
oh junkrat oh he's dead get out of here
they just like they were doing so well
outside just inside they just couldn't
figure out what to do i'm hoping for a
play of the game from that last part i
think
yeah
i love that victory pose
just him and his turret chilling
oh man
dang of course sebastian let's see uh
this better be good bastion
oh from the church
yeah
a couple
oh we got that that was one i heard that
we had no idea where it was that rip
tire
before not bad
did you just vote for yourself no oh you
just voted for yourself
you just tried to cough to cover it
right that sound yeah you just like
coughed over when it i don't talk about
all right
so we got like another half hour
probably like i had no idea how many
matches that could that could be like
that could be four matches that could be
seven
could be one
no it couldn't be one
well i mean yeah if you're in overtime
for the half an hour but that doesn't
happen i'm only like 25 minutes right
did you want to get on you want to keep
you want me playing or what you keep
playing because i can't do mouse and
keyboard all right
who should i go has anybody seen genji
today i can go genji
but i really like him
i'll play him just to show him
if you're just now tuning in this is our
all day stream of overwatch uh actually
though we're about to take a little
break for the lobby in about a half an
hour or so
um so be sure to check that out and then
come back and we'll be watching or we'll
be playing more overwatch um i don't
know who's going on after us though to
play hey and mary mary uh they're i
think they're closing out the day like
so they're gonna be a long time 3 30 to
5 30 or something no he'll just keep
playing until he collapses at the desk
um
yeah
i know mary uh
mary and rob
and uh are kind of some of the more
recent people to join overwatch but
they're you know they're getting good um
mary's mary's been playing for a while
rob has been dabbling with a few
characters so i think we almost have a
full 6v6 in like the office which is
awesome for like the private games i
heard uh chris getting frustrated with
rob the other day when they were playing
but rob couldn't hear because his
headphones were in and
chris was like robert hanlery robert
handler and he just like didn't
respond
i am ready
so the cool thing about this sword dash
is that if you kill someone that resets
it's not that powerful though it's main
it's good for like actually dashing them
so you got those three round bursts you
got the spread
i love that reload thing it comes out of
his wrist and i think we talked about it
a little bit but what's uh what's the
best tactic for genji he's a good
one-on-one character his deflection can
really mess people up so you kind of
have to be patient with him you might
not kill him right away he's not going
to do a ton of damage right away unless
you're you know it's always good i've
noticed if you can land all three of
those
oh it's a hanzo all right if you land
all through those shurikens it does
quite a bit of damage or ninja stars
whatever for sure
but it's pretty tough to land all three
oh [ __ ] i just
peppered that thing you didn't notice
nope
oh there we go
is that lucio
yep
all right we're making moves doing
something
what
where how did you just die it was may
did she
you know what happened it might have
happened
she might have thrown down a trap as
widowmaker
i have no idea
heroes never die i mean she has the trap
this little spider
trap that she can throw but
i don't know
i think that happens sometimes when it's
just something about a character i
forget about us along with the chat has
convinced filius 32 to get overwatch
nice
phillies 32 so in for a good game
this is one of the few games in recent
memory that the art style alone was like
or just the art direction i was like
yeah i'm gonna play that i don't care
what kind of game it is
not not alone but like the art style
initially the first thing i saw but i
was like oh that looks awesome the
characters just the characters are just
unreal the disney or like the disney
like sort of pixar like launch trailer
that they showed off like i i felt the
same way but then actually seen the game
play like i had no interest in it and i
think what i really had interest when uh
when the beta started and i just heard
danny and andy talking about sure how
awesome it was
man
let us hope for a different outcome yeah
wild card says the hardest habit to
break with genji is taking the stairs
and you just wall climb i know yeah he
could just jump up
because him and hanzo both uh hanzo
leaps a little over legend what not
and then lucio you kind of forget he's
the walking
bless you forget he has the wall runs
all right
i should probably
probably use that because they're all
kind of clumped up
thank you for not sneezing in my
direction this time yeah sorry
congrat you were there
oh you
oh
wow i wasted that one
they were kind of ready for that bastion
on offense is always a surprise but
effective the user right
wow
uh i think everybody likes him
i mean i haven't played him yet uh rob
that's rob's character
yeah get out of here widowmaker oh that
is super weird so
yeah so that was a widowmaker whose name
blizzard tag is battle net tag is may so
that's why i said kill that's why it
confused me so it was her spider
century i believe
some
next level meta right there changing
your tag name to throw people off yeah
all right let's get behind these dudes
nice
kind of mccree
happening
it was a good spot to chuck those into
not good enough though
so off the top of your head do you know
your favorite map you're saying there's
one you really really like gibraltar um
it's the one where you it's got a couple
of walkways you go into a factory from
like the initial i like route 66 as well
a lot actually
on defense cool i love the art style
route 66 too
for sure
pass into the iris
damn it
mccree's pretty good against most other
offensive characters
yeah with that flashbang
is that
so the yellow one is damage buff right
health uh damage
oh
dang
short-lived mae got ya
with her ice sniper
nice shot whatever who cares
i just love that even like
what they're all to look like kind of
the dragons that come out for hanzo and
genji are similar
obviously big brothers
rather than the same mother
oh i think you can get a couple
oh damn it hey you got no never mind
nope she eliminated you
she's good
think she's gonna get the play of the
game probably i wouldn't be surprised
i'm probably the one that should i need
i'm the one that just kill her too
do you not like widowmaker that much
playing as her yeah no i do um i'm just
not as good as like a lot of people like
danny's pretty good yeah i've been doing
a while since i played something like
counter-strikey like that
even though in counter-strike i played
mainly arsenal
oh that's not good
i should use my old soon
we're almost there
i should have gotten the objective i was
just trying to distract them
looks like they're oh are we pushing it
back
they are or they're pushing it back
30 seconds remaining
are there any characters that like
like what are your least favorite
characters are the characters you never
want to play are there any or do you
pretty much enjoy
oh come on yeah there we go
oh wow
um
not really i don't use symmetra all that
often but she is a really cool character
which one is symmetra i haven't used i
haven't
teleport the warp portals and the sentry
turrets
she puts she's the one that puts down
those
warp portals
they're like portal sort of they
teleport you from wherever to wherever
it's like yeah portal portal oh it's
pretty cool
all right gotta get on that
oh
and then which character is that the
floating one zenyatta zenyatta or
character
another one i haven't touched yet
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
nice so that's our rock barrage come on
yeah i want to learn genji way more i'm
not good with him but he's fun to play
i've met things going on i have my
moments with him i'm like this character
is awesome but then most of the time i
just get my butt kicked [ __ ] oh
all right i might have to branch off i'm
not gonna stick around for that
oh that reload
okay that wouldn't make a probably sees
me coming up
junkrat you do not want to go against
that
what happened to that widowmaker she's
down there i'm shooting at her can't hit
her though oh she's always come on yeah
oh nice
got her finally
oh my god that's annoying
oh there you go
got some backup
geez did you not get any points for that
no this one you hit him a couple of
times i did but
mainly
mainly reinhardt
oh
all right come on
yeah philly's 32 if you have not if you
didn't get a chance to play the beta i'd
recommend trying ai um just for a couple
rounds figure things out figure out what
characters you like
um because some people have probably
played this a lot already somebody get
on out damn it we're no
no
it's over
damn dang
you guys were close it was a valiant
effort yeah
that diva was pretty good oh man
self-destruct that was good
i don't think i got killed by a
self-destruct but that was
two three
four people
man
it was really good
diva is another one i haven't tried
she's really funny she looks like she'd
be fun
i heard when she's uh when she's not in
her suit though she's like pretty
vulnerable 15 players resurrected uh
yeah she's hard to hit though
i might open that loot box while we're
here
getting into a new game anyway okay time
for
definitely one more maybe probably two
maybe three
come on give me something damn it
it's cool again i like that skin
not bad
i like the backdrop are you is this are
you playing hollywood next is that the
deal
or is it just just it just ran
um all right where are we headed next
play someone i haven't yet
who haven't i played i played there's a
bunch um
junkrat i haven't played junker i really
like congrats yeah you should do some
junkrat junkrat's pretty fun to watch
especially trapping people in those bear
traps and then
blasting them
he also looks insane yeah having roadhog
like partnered up in australian uh
omnic waste reserve wasteland or
something parts of australia to the
robots and then so it's like a mad max
sort of deal that's pretty cool
so is are the tips of his hair on fire
yeah
how's his hair still there i don't know
pyro explosive
maniac i feel like everybody has a
cybernetic arm in this game
like everyone mccree has one
genji's almost all cyborg
who knows what she's got she's got like
a egyptian security torbjorn
it's got a wrench
i feel like you got the short end of the
stick i know reaper's just some angel of
death i don't know these characters are
awesome
let's play some
junkrat i love how you can see his uh
peg leg limp in the gun the way the gun
moves i know
all right
so what's uh
what's our junk rat strategy here
um pretty much just kind of
close off choke points with uh bear
traps in the
detonation mines he's good for
disrupting enemy uh tanks with a
detonation mine um he's also good for
just
like getting those hard shots in there
from where this grenade like i just
started lobbying yeah
he's not that great at close range and
he can hurt himself
you really need to practice the grenade
launcher in order to
get good enough a pharah we need a
sniper or something if we don't happen
against her
thank god for unlimited ammo
yeah mccree you got trapped
sounded like troy baker it's troy baker
okay i'm gonna i'm just gonna call it
right now definitely troy baker
put that again there i like that
i don't like that spot as much as the
other one though
can you move it
not that you should but can you keep it
on my trap move it
[ __ ] [ __ ] what just killed it i don't
know oh someone killed him while he's my
trap tracer i do not want to go up
against the tracer
yeah no that's not gonna work so you can
do that and then you can do that so any
time it sets trigger just detonate it
that's pretty cool i love how he's
holding it out the entire time too
yeah
he's holding it there
all right i'm not i don't want to mess
with this tracer someone's up there no
that's ours
i don't know where that tracer is making
me nervous oh [ __ ]
oh
lucio's up there too
get out of here nice
there goes tracer hello
i feel like someone's gotta walk into
that sooner or later
oh oh
reapers
got those sides covered
oh man
sentry and me
yeah that's
convenient for him
ah
the chat has confirmed oh mccree is
voiced by baker nice
nolan north is probably in here
somewhere too i'm just joking but
seriously
he's probably like may or something like
that last person you'd expect
nathan drake may or widowmaker
okay
got my rip tire rip tire you want to
round corners and use it because
otherwise it takes if they touch it with
anything it it doesn't work
explodes this is a hard point to push if
you're on offense like this first one
for
dorado
oh that's why that didn't hit him
i'm sorry yeah
so what's your favorite alt then i
really like rip tire rip tires
that's pretty cool
where is everyone
there's a guy in there
damn oh you got him got one ah he killed
me while i was out there that reaper uh
i like
alt is probably deadeye but it takes a
while to get used to
um i really like graviton surge uh
zarya's
rip tire is really fun to just use
i just wish his he didn't just like
just sit there
like yeah i mean you trade you trade the
power you have with the explosive
vulnerability yeah it makes sense but i
hate that i'm comparing it well no i
don't it's like call of duty when you
called in like uh predator strikes or
anything if you ever do that rc c4
whatever ac 130.
i think rc c4 is a droid oh no what's
that i know i don't know what it's
called but like there's that dumb remote
control car in black ops that
you drove around and blow up on people
or cxd
oh you're talking about
the ac 130s
a beast
you got him
her
damn it thing
come on
they might push it they got up there
finally
just from watching you play zara and
watching her play sorry i can tell i
would not like zarya
she takes some getting used to
you gotta really be like paying
attention
just reaper get away from me i want to
deal with you right now
they are
obscenely close
i think yeah
they got it
oh do they
oh off the ramp
i got one whatever oh that might have
been better than nothing
oh they'd
damn it
oh they got it all right
yeah there's like dust on this mic he's
sneezing
someone forgot to de-dust the mics
maybe you should just stop snorting the
dust off the mics and he'd be fine
what none of those hit her come on
man
yeah
i panic man right when like
i'm in close quarters of the grenade
yeah
whatever
don't even care
all right
coming up on a spot where i can yeah
they're pushing it pretty steadily
a couple tracers oh that's fun
especially for junkrat
they could charge you so easily if they
wanted to go around here
underrated most underrated alt is uh
widowmaker's probably x-ray oh maybe not
underrated people realize the value it's
just it's not like it's not fun really
like it's yeah
but it especially for widowmaker for
hanzos it's great
for [ __ ]
i think you can pull it off
yeah i think your team's got it gotta go
up that hill
pushing it back a little bit no one
seems to be falling for your traps
though i know
they're smarter than i am
where's that pharah the fair i'm waiting
for to fly over the fence
uh oh uh oh you know what time it is
damn we really halted them right there
kind of worried about where they are
well there's one right there
damn reaper
couple tracers reaper they're really
mobile team
the hunter plays a trap for his prey
okay i'm not really doing much
experience
so what's that dude they'll just heal
yep and he's invulnerable for a little
bit it's really good
that's actually really good alt too
he can't do anything else besides heal
but he still can't get hurt while he's
there here's that reaper
30 seconds 30 seconds
all right they're gonna start pushing
pushing good
this is where my rip fire is going to be
sweet yeah
hopefully
i've got one at least something yeah it
would have waited i think a little
longer right until you started
oh
those
a good point
you guys are pushing them back too so
yeah we're good
all right what do you think one more
yeah we got time for one more all right
then we're gonna
call it here
man i feel like bastian gets
plays the games yep every time
that's the one thing i don't like um
it's not a huge complaint but
the post-match voting period is really
good about encouraging it shows you that
you know like oh you can you know you
can hook enemies it's really good you
get
recovering health as tracer like it
encourages different play styles other
than it just kills
the play of the game is
in
i don't know 80 percent of the time is a
kill streak which
once in a while it's a really good
revive as mercy but i wish the play of
the game kind of encouraged uh
filling different roles like the
voting period did and you know like when
you select your team it says oh you know
the tank right now you have a healer and
it's like okay i should try to play
something outside my comfort zone
play the game just doesn't really always
shine the light on the
lesser known heroes i guess you could
say you can see your own play at the
games though right
uh yes
i like full sky industries on defense
all right this is my last match so
who don't want to play
i don't know should we ask the chat
sure
what should what should mike play for
his last
game see if there's any response
how long should we give it another five
seconds another five seconds all right
all right
all right never mind then
i was going bastion i don't think
anybody else can be playing bastion
right now
now you know what i'll go diva yeah do
diva i want to see diva
oh someone just chimed in reaper
too late yeah reaper no i can go oh you
wanna switch reaper all right
but tay is gonna be playing reaper a lot
later i'll do reaper for like until i
die but tay is gonna be playing i'm
assuming tail be playing reaper oh
that's a sick
skin
he's got a beanie and everything that
means he's hardcore yeah
so yeah tay's really good with reaper i
think that's one of his mains um i'll go
deep after this but we're waiting for
reaper on defense is fun because you
could just get right behind their lines
and everything kind of like tracer
they're up they're pushers but they're
good pushing on defense too
repositioning
i love his reload he just gets rid of
the guns yeah
pulls two more from
who knows where
i don't know if you ever saw the old uh
2006 punisher movie 2004
and there's that one scene where he's in
the bank and he just like unloads his
pistols throws him on the ground pulls
out two more unloads and throws them on
the ground
so it reminds me of
until you know you're bad ass when you
don't care about your pistols just throw
them on the ground
oh damn i thought she would have gotten
past her oh you just wanted to see what
skin you were using
i'll play before
uh yeah i'm using the pre-order skin
origins edition
is that origins editions that's the
pre-order one
uh
yeah there's well there's a regular
origin position i believe but pre-order
pre-ordering if you pre-order the game
you get um
widowmaker's noir
um skin which i don't have so you're
saying people should go pre-order this
game
not what i'm saying well it's a good
game but yeah but they can't they can't
pre-order
okay i get what you're
saying i'll go diva i'll let tay show
someone playing reaper well later
yeah dude is really fun
definitely very tight and folly
guns are not that long range at all
run
dang
so what's her best strategy
um
i don't know using the
self-destruct at the right time i mean
flying the flying helps a lot like uh
trying to get above she's good for
getting up the top areas but you kind of
want to be medium range with her look
short range because her
she's got the shield which is temporary
so you need no one to throw that out but
i can tell by just looking at the
reticle that she's kind of short range
oh
i don't know why we're all just
yeah no you got to get closer
so you mentioned that as a south korean
professional gamer
and then they recruiters like an ender's
game kind of story they recruited her
because to do that stuff
um you mentioned you can like
the the rig that she's in explodes
so when it when it dies does it explode
or can you like auto
you're gonna just uh like
manually explode like well it's her alt
okay
does it so um it that that just blows up
um in other cases when you have her all
she because you want to actually be
doing damage in her pilot form because
that speeds up the
when you get your
mech back that makes sense so it's
pretty
you can't just really hang back as this
form i mean you could be
oh yeah they got it locked down pretty
well
looks like they've got a healer over
there too
all right sweet
oh she's pretty mobile too
for short bursts yeah and that the
cooldown is really fast you want to use
it as much you can
of course i think lucio's gonna have no
trouble getting away from you
no
because he's really mobile
so what did you just do there oh that
was your i combined the flying with the
self-destruct but yeah it didn't really
get that much done but i can get it back
fast so there's armor someone's playing
target
seems like their whole team's pretty
fast
yeah except for roadhog
oh
oh that's something i want to be doing
right now
i mean but it seems like whatever you're
doing is working you're keeping away
from this yeah
oh there we go now we got slower guys
coming up
oh yeah yeah zarya get in there
dang
this would be a really good time to have
my alt i know
i'm doing
they don't really
there we go
oh no oh man i didn't like that
uh yes
yeah it's like you've got everyone like
the rip tires really good against
reinhardt yeah there's a few
so you like it kind of force you to be
her gun even looks like a nerf gun i
know it does but it encourages you to
there's a lot of layers that just kind
of reveal themselves the more you play
the game so you might want to hang back
and wait for that to recharge but you
get up here you can get it much faster
getting her more powerful version
how long you have to wait until you can
get in her mech suit again well see
that's once you reach uh once you get
her all charged again but by doing
damage within this form you speed that
process up because you're also charged
faster when you're damaged or healing or
whatever
and we hurt her machine is not pushover
someone brought up in the chat that it's
surprising that this game works day one
it seems like normally there's so many
server issues in yeah
all these problems and like miraculously
this is damn working fine i guess that's
why they did so many beta tests though
yeah i mean it took ten minutes to get
up after four o'clock and they said it
would but that might have been just like
a you know initiation kind of scheduling
error
i mean when you have 10 million people
in your beta you have a pretty good idea
of how much stress you can handle yeah
don't give it to them now
oh no
fair see pharaoh's like fair is a really
good counter to
i should use the all right there damn it
this is not looking good for you that
was my fault i should use the alt
just get in it's not looking good you
can test it
contest it oh man
get back in there get back in there
oh you i feel like i know i'm just
trying to stay there i know you're doing
good well yeah you held out for such a
long time that torbjorn is kind of just
more than enough time for your team to
get there and that right lend a hand
i said hand fine
come on
is that he's that he's dead getting in
getting getting getting get in
oh you guys are still holding it yeah
kill that lucio
he's the one making things different
they only have
[ __ ] i do not want to go up against the
river right now oh
damn there it is
you put up quite the fight i didn't i
could use that all a little better but
yeah all right well
so i think that's it for us it's
overwatch at least for now so in about a
half an hour so 20 minutes we're gonna
start the point so make sure to stick
around for that and after the point we
are going to continue streaming
overwatch so you haven't had enough of
it
make sure to come back and i think mary
and tay will be joining yeah
be playing reaper and may and a few
characters you haven't seen yet uh we
try to get through as many as we could
today probably get through everybody but
yeah cool um
yesterday on twitch and game spot for
the lobby we're talking about overwatch
fallout 4 far harbor um
yesterday or today was gamespot's 20th
anniversary we're talking about that too
on the lotte at some point yeah so it
should be a good episode and your review
for this goes up yeah 6 a.m pacific uh 9
eastern tomorrow yeah before have a
score and everything be
longer than my review in progress uh get
more in depth of things
it's all set it's all edited yeah ready
to go up we'll see you guys in a bit
you